hey guys pete here
it's time to talk about better call saul
season 6 episode 10.
nippy was a return to something more
like the first couple of seasons of
better call salt and the first full gene
episode that we've been waiting so long
to see i mean this is something that
i've been waiting for
since the first episode of the first
season
so today i have
just one
co-host one person here to talk uh but
i'm gonna let him introduce himself and
tell us what he thought about the
episode
and then i'm gonna come back and uh
respond to that and we'll go through
some things and we'll answer all your
questions
so go ahead chase why don't you
introduce yourself and let me know what
you thought about this episode
for sure hey guys kiwi here what's going
on chat um i thought this episode was
pretty cool kind of felt a bit like a
fever dream though with the uh the
different jeff actor i like i like the
new jeff actor at the same time i miss
the old jeff actor and uh
i like the way that the new jeff actor
played he kind of seemed a little bit
more uh a little bit more pathetic
honestly or like less intimidating in
moments i almost felt bad for him
uh it seemed like he kind of just wanted
a friend and uh jimmy kind of her gene
flipped that on him but i like what you
said about it uh feeling like kind of
the earlier seasons a better call saul
because that's what it really comes down
to i don't think it's a bad episode i
think it's a pretty good episode it's
not one of my top episodes but i i did
quite enjoy it and throughout rewatches
um i really like it aside from that
cinnabon eating montage man that that
food eating asmr really gets to me but
uh
but yeah yeah i definitely liked the
episode what did uh what do you think
well you know it was kind of one of
those episodes that was
uh
a this
with a butt you know what i mean like it
was sort of a call back to the first
siege season which i really liked you
know what i mean like to
different uh you know just kind of
self-contained and just
dealing with this one character and
getting to know him again
but at the same time none of the other
original characters are are there
anymore you know what i mean
uh it's a totally different situation
and like it was funny there were so many
funny parts in this but after the last
episode in the last few episodes
there's something different underneath
the surface of that so it's sort of like
you know i was sitting there and and i
really enjoy it for what it was
but it was also kind of you know
it also had this weird feeling to me of
like what's really going on here you
know what i mean like you can't really
expect that
he's going to
you know figure out this problem fix it
and then still have three episodes left
and you know something isn't about to
happen somewhere you know what i mean
like i kind of added all this extra
extra tension expecting something to
come
and it never did so you know on some
level i felt a little unsatisfied at the
end i wanted to see more
but i think you know and this is what i
talked about in my video i think the
most was that
what i what i really like about that
when i look back on it is is that like
it's crazy to not know where they go
next you know i mean it's crazy to be
this into it to watch all of it and be
completely in tune
and yet
i don't know what's going to happen next
week really
you know what i mean
yeah it's pretty crazy it was quite a
tone shift too and i feel like maybe
some disappointment from some fans may
just be due to the fact that we've been
waiting like two years for another gene
scene or a gene episode is our first
ever gene episode which is wild um it's
crazy how seamlessly just the black and
white flowed throughout the entire
episode and it was quite a tone shift i
feel like
i feel like this episode kind of brought
it down to earth a little bit because
near the end of the better call salt
timeline with wallow and howard and all
of that stuff really hit the fan and
with the breaking bad timeline obviously
it's just wild stuff happening all the
time but with gene you know just working
at a cinnabon doing his thing i mean i
feel like it was more more grounded in
that sense um you know gene going and
talking to the mall cops he has this
whole elaborate uh montage which i loved
by the way uh just timing the guy eating
a cinnabon so it felt
a lot like you know early season
slipping jimmy cons in that regards it
wasn't wasn't it wasn't necessarily life
or death but at the same time i think
that fits gene in the sense of he's just
living an everyday life and uh
i i do like the way that um
you know initially you think that he's
training uh jeff but then he flips it on
him and he kind of set him up just to
get him off his back i like the way they
did that instead of him just trying to
bribe him or something like that or
maybe taking more of a lethal approach
i wonder if we're going to see any more
of jeff in the future it seems like this
episode kind of wrapped up his arc
pretty well
but at the same time i wouldn't mind
seeing more of him at least a little bit
maybe like one or two more scenes uh for
getting depending how much more gene
we're gonna get i would like to see a
more uh carol burnetta's marion i really
like i really like the chemistry between
her and uh bob owen kirk in this episode
i thought that was great and i think
it's so cool how easily she he uh he
wins her over just because jimmy was
always good with elders right and i
think that really really shows here i
really really loved like the earlier
seasons with jimmy doing elder law and
and how well he won them over i mean of
course the
the irene bingo scene at the end of
season three is always heartbreaking but
uh
aside from that i always love the elder
interactions and i i hope see more from
her i don't know if we will i don't know
if this is the only episode she's gonna
be in but i'm definitely open to it
yeah and and like i was saying before it
is it's it's one of those things where
all of what you said and all of what you
liked there i really enjoyed
but
you know i just don't know
i just don't know where it where it goes
from here you know what i mean because
jimmy
slash saul
gene
um you know this is
he was he was mostly just paranoid this
episode kind of gives it away that it's
about six months after he he disappeared
i think it you know it narrows it down
pretty good there
um
that would be just like a month or so
after walter white died
back in albuquerque so
you know there's a possibility that
that's on the news that's something that
might be on people's minds it might be a
bad time for him
to sort of
you know raise his profile but he
doesn't he doesn't really have a choice
you know this is one of those situations
where you kind of hate to see him go
back into his old behaviors but what
else could he do here like you said you
know he he flipped it around on jeff
jeff had real power over him you know
you can you remember that from the last
scene when he's telling him to say the
say the thing you know and he and he's
kind of taunting him in a way
and it's like you know what can gene do
he has to say whatever this guy wants
there's a cop standing over there just a
few feet away and if if you know if this
guy makes trouble for him then he could
go to prison for for a long time for for
what we know
so yeah it's sort of an inevitable thing
that had to happen
but you have all this other stuff now of
knowing like how why he became saul what
what that's all about
how he lives here and and you know he
was basically distracting himself while
he was back in albuquerque now he's here
he has none of that distraction
he looks bored he looks paranoid he
looks miserable
that makes sense to us because we you
know we know the character we know what
his history is and then you know seeing
him get a taste of that old life
it's not necessarily you know he does he
does like you know brighten up and get
excited and and he looks happy at work
for the first time but it's all sort of
like but at what cost you know what i
mean because
there's a slippery slope out there
that's just waiting for him
and you know it's it's it's interesting
that he puts the clothes down at the end
but you know where where do we go from
there you know that's the big question
we got a a few super chats piling up
here so i want to go ahead and get
through a few of these before
we move on did you have anything else
you wanted to um say there about what i
just mentioned
uh yeah yeah i just wanted to add i
think i think that it's uh fair to say
that gene probably casually drowns
himself in uh booze every night once he
gets home just to try and not think
about everything that's on his mind
you can really tell that he hasn't
really thought about his family or chuck
in a while considering especially
considering the way he pauses when he
mentions that his brother's dead and i
really like that touch and yeah i feel
like the more we go into it's inevitable
uh discussing uh the new jeff actor
versus the old jeff actor so sure we'll
get more into that but yeah i'm excited
to see where this goes from here and how
much he diverts back into saul or slip
and jimmy or what what that that's gonna
look like
yeah in a lot of ways i thought this was
more of a jimmy coming out you know just
because it does really feel more like
season one or season two of the show
and the self-contained nature it didn't
really feel
it didn't feel it felt more connected to
that than it did to that last uh you
know episode nine flash forward to where
we see him in frantic saw mode you know
what i mean
especially with marco's rain coming out
you know that's um yeah literally
early season vibes there
that's an essential part of of who
slipping jimmy is right
all right mike camparil thank you for
the 10
that's very generous um big mac 076
thank you for the 9.99
when gene started to break down and cry
it reminded me of the scene in breaking
bad where walt starts crying in hank's
office so he could plant the bug on his
computer
uh yeah i could see that i mean it's
kind of a different situation though
isn't it um
walt goes in there with the intention of
manipulating him if i remember it's been
a while since i've seen that scene you
know
but i think uh my my recollection is
that um
you know this is this is something he
had planned whereas jimmy is he's he's
thinking this up in the moment and he's
pulling on some real life um
you know stuff that he has
and using it to his advantage do you do
you have a do you ever do you remember
this scene in
i mean i remember him planning it but i
don't remember all of the details
leading up to it exactly do you have any
remember uh memory of that
yeah i vaguely remember i i rewatched
breaking bad at some point between
season five and season six i better call
saul
um i i just i just remember walt may
kind of making hank feel a little bit
awkward and then he eventually leaves
the room to get him some water or
something and that's when he gets the
opportunity to plant the bug but i do
agree that with walt it was more
premeditated and gene it was on the
moment in the moment he was just kind of
grasping at straws thinking of anything
he could do to steal the spotlight from
the security cameras i i do love the way
that he's he's trying to keep the uh
trying to keep the mall cops attention
but at the same time he's constantly
looking over them all cops shoulder at
the cameras and i like i like the point
where he uh he's talking about how if he
dies he'll be a ghost he'll be a shadow
and as he says that he'll be a shadow
he's kind of looking over the mall cobb
shoulder towards the security camera in
the same way that in 607 he was looking
over howard's shoulder and actually saw
wallow's shower so i don't know if that
was intentional or not but i thought
that was a nice touch and um at the same
time i feel like uh
i i feel like gene sort of fake mental
breakdown here might have ruined his
mall cop friendship but that uh that
might have been for the best uh just
because he just kind of you know
made this friendship come to fruition
just specifically for this scheme so you
know it's kind of a double-edged sword
where uh this guy might not want to talk
to him so much anymore but i might be
for the best
yeah the the um
the breakdown here you know it's he he
reacts to it a lot different than um
than hank did hank was sort of like ooh
you know i i feel uncomfortable i want
to get out of the room which was was
walt's uh that's what walt wanted to
happen
but here this guy he he he's sympathetic
but at the same time he's sort of like
no not me that doesn't happen to me like
so what you i thought the same same
thing you thought that after the fact
it might be like he might understand why
he doesn't come anymore you know because
it was just awkward and now they now
they don't talk about it you know
yeah definitely kind of like i don't
know when you meet a new person and they
seem chill at first and you're hanging
out with them or you see them from time
to time and then you just get this one
weird moment with them that just kind of
makes you feel a little bit off put
where you still like them but it just
you kind of kind of really look at them
the same way
yeah
it's all fun and games until somebody
starts crying starts sobbing about their
you know talking about the problems of
their life
out of nowhere douglas
yeah bc douglas thank you for the dollar
will dean have to get a dog to keep the
marion con going i i don't think this is
a bad question um i think we're gonna
you know we're gonna end up talking
about this more
because the end of this episode kind of
it you know it felt it had that
self-contained feeling it felt like it
was handling a major problem that the
show posed which was how was he going to
get out from underneath jeff
you know
but
there's also three episodes left so we
do have to consider that they may spend
a lot of time in you know this this gene
timeline and you know that is something
that could come up uh if marion does
decide like i mentioned at the end of my
video to you know to kind of come after
him um you know i think there's a hint i
think there's a hint that she might be a
more familiar formidable foe than um
her son
i think you know that she was definitely
you know the one that that was calling
the shots in the house
it's definitely possible that she could
uh know what her son was up to and know
what happened i think that
when i was watching it initially when
they're in the in the kitchen at the end
i was totally expecting
her to turn just because of the person
that she is the uh
the um
you know the
the kind of actor that carol burnett is
and the kind of range that she has so
you know i was thinking like she's
playing this this nice uh friendly mom
who who's harmless but
there could definitely be another layer
underneath there that we're not seeing
and kind of the whole part of her saying
um
you know you're a good influence on him
and and whatever it seemed like
that was something that you could you
could say that she was subtly you know
telling him that she knew more than than
what what he thinks that he was you know
sort of underestimating her but
i don't think it really
i don't think we really know until we
get
to the next episode
that's really and that's a real
interesting uh
way to read between the lines i
definitely ate up the fact that she was
uh just kind of a an innocent old lady
you know they're just just a sweet old
lady but that'd be crazy if she actually
had another layer to that where she uh
she's a little bit more diabolical or
she can she can get down to brass tacks
uh so to speak and uh
and actually be uh intimidating in the
same way that uh say gene was to uh to
jeff when he was kind of telling him off
i think that'd be really interesting uh
to see i'm not sure if she would be much
of a much of a threat but i think i
think that'd be interesting if she was
the thing that actually took down gene
and um in regards to him getting a dog i
think i think that'd be interesting i'd
i'd like to see it i feel like it would
help with gene's loneliness at least a
little bit uh
so he's not at that in that entire house
you know alone maybe bring some life in
into his world i think that'd be
interesting
yeah he's talking about bringing life
into their world the other thing i kept
waiting for waiting to happen when i was
watching this episode was i was waiting
for that thing that was gonna you know
like you mentioned his ring or
you know whenever he does anything in
this episode i kept thinking oh the
colors are gonna come back you know i'm
waiting for this dramatic moment where
where uh omaha goes from black and white
to color and of course that never came
yeah yeah same
space windu thank you for the five hell
pete and kiwi uh thank you for that i
was scrolling through here i i saw some
people um
mentioning courtney uh she's gonna be on
on saturday she wasn't able to make it
on tuesday and the reason why it's just
me and kiwi today is because uh
gil had something come up at the last
minute and he had to back out that's or
else i would have had somebody else on
but um
things will be back to normal next week
and we will be continuing with the
saturday stream
as well
poisson terry thank you for the two
dollars i'm calling the gene timeline
baking bad from now on that's pretty
good
i didn't thought of that but now i will
t thank you for the 499 my two favorite
bcs channels thank you for the great
content i fanboyed out when gene
referenced a certain 50 year old
chemistry teacher
yeah well that's that was the other
thing is that you know deadline
hollywood or one of those magazines
confirmed that they were going to be
back
and so you know i spent most of the
episode wondering how how will we go
back into that timeline because
obviously you know they're not going to
show up
and then we got this mess you know this
mention and it was
the way it was played and what he said
and and the whole thing was it was a
great you know it was like wow you know
it really it really brought back
feelings of of
enjoying that the breaking bad you know
series when it was on
and then you're like well wait a minute
that's not that's not what they meant
that that um
you know walt and jesse will show up and
uh i don't know it was kind of weird
that kind of had a you know it didn't
it didn't take me out of it as much as
um
just the just like how i felt
disoriented by the the way the story was
playing out at times but you know it was
um
i i definitely was ex you know waiting
based on what they said that that walton
jesse would actually show up
did you experience that
yeah yes yeah so what the heck was with
that deadline article a cause i think
there was a deadline article that uh
said that uh i think aaron paul
apparently confirmed that jesse was
supposed to be in the last episode i'll
have to uh
go and uh look at that again to see if i
uh misread something yeah it was real
interesting i was expecting them to
appear last episode i'm not disappointed
that they didn't you know uh there's
still time for that and we know we're
still gonna get it here eventually i
thought that was real interesting that
they didn't um i really liked the way
that they mentioned walt uh not
necessarily by name but he used it uh
as sort of a braggadocious way in order
to keep jeff on board because you can
tell that jeff
kind of looks up to him in regards to
the fact that he was involved with the
heisenberg case and everything that
comes along with it so
i feel like he's using uh that example
from his past life in order to uh try
and star struck him a little bit and
make him uh stay you know
stay stay on track and uh i really liked
that i don't think they overdid it i
don't think they under did it i thought
it was pretty interesting and i like the
way they executed it for sure
yeah i was wondering that if that was
the general consensus with it was that
he said that in the way that he said it
to kind of you know
to kind of pull on that on on that the
pull on the uh what would be the word
like the mystique around heisenberg you
know i mean like jeff should know
who he's referring to but but it never
gets to like him being able to ask a
question about it or
you know
discuss it more he just sort of he just
sort of delivers in a way that he you
know he puts it there he's sort of like
yeah you know don't forget i was i was
heisenberg's guy kind of thing you know
what i mean and then
and then moves on
roger rubio thank you for the ten
dollars shout out to my two favorite bcs
youtubers big thank you for all the hard
work
so we have no idea where the last three
episodes will go do you think we go to
the breaking bad uh break breaking bad
era next question mark or more gene
question mark
well i i did listen to the insider
podcast and i've seen
when i went to pull these photos i saw
some photos from 611
so
i i don't know if that's like kind of
spoilery or not
i guess my my takeaway at the end of the
episode was that
it seemed like they would have to
spend some more time in the gene
timeline because
i don't know how they could i don't know
how they could find an ending in the
break not because it felt like it was it
was the natural progression from where
they were at necessarily but because
they're how can they find an ending in
the breaking bad timeline there's really
nothing that they need to
to answer there or do there really you
know i mean we know just because they
announced it that
that um walt and jesse are gonna show up
and i think that they'll probably have a
good reason when when they get there but
but i don't need to there's nothing
about walt or jesse that that i don't
know that i'm i'm dying to find out you
know what i mean i want whatever they're
doing to to serve
saul's story
and i don't know how you i don't know
how you work backwards and come up with
an ending to his story there
does that make sense
yeah yeah i just think it's real
interesting the way they kind of just
showed like the uh
the pre-walt breaking bad timeline a
little bit that's at the end of 609 and
then they jump right into gene i wonder
if we're mainly going to be focusing on
gene for the remaining four episodes or
what the deal is there i don't mind at
all that we're jumping forward through
time and we might jump back through time
go back to the breaking bad timeline for
walt and jesse i just find that
interesting i don't know why i just kind
of always figured we'd go in
chronological order so we'd have some a
breaking bad episode or two before gene
uh but now i'm really curious how much
time we're actually gonna spend in the
breaking bad timeline in regards to walt
and jesse if we're just gonna do sort of
a an extended cold open where we get all
three scenes with them back to back to
back um or if it's actually going to be
spread throughout an episode if it's
going to be spread throughout multiple
different episodes um i'm not too sure i
find that really interesting though
yeah i i think that um
what
you know i think that the
they have to spend more time in
in gene you know in the gene timeline
and that makes it even more interesting
that they decided to end this on a win
like that you know
so we'll see how it plays out
jordan grist thank you for the five
dollars this episode happens in october
2010 based on the sports references from
frank unranked texas beasts nebraska in
college football on october 6
2010
and yes i i mentioned this in my video
as well
it does seem to put it you know right in
the october there's some things that
don't make sense if you really nitpick
at it but
college football happens when college
football happens you know
maybe it's not usually snowing at that
time of year but
i think you have to go with that because
that's you know the
them mentioning those games are really
specific and and it's something that
happens at the same time every year it's
not variable at all
so yeah i i i think you can you can
firmly put this in october of 2010
um
that would mean that that he's been
there for about six months
at this point
a little over six months since since he
was disappeared
he's been gene he's been living an
unassuming life in
as the manager of cinnabon
and walter white died in september of
2010.
like i mentioned earlier you know it
could be a situation where
you know that's been on the news even
lately and that could come up
in the future what's left
yeah i've always i've always liked the
idea of uh kim richard or kim returning
to the gene timeline because she sees
um all of the news with the heisenberg
case and the fact that saul's
disappeared or maybe maybe there's a
manhunt for him or something like that i
would just
i'm not necessarily saying that she's
gonna track down gene because of it but
i would like to see her reaction to
seeing uh all of that on the news
yeah
that would be cool and one other thing
that you know i didn't really mention
this in the video that i made yesterday
but
one it definitely
having this part of the story resolved
or that step of the story i don't know
if you would say it's a part because
like we keep saying there there's there
could definitely there could be more
that come out of this scam he just
pulled but
you know to have it have him have him
conceive of and pull off a scam
and successfully change the situation
with jeff
that does open up the idea of what i was
talking about on saturday and that would
be to get a full kim episode or a kim
heavy episode at least to find out what
she's doing in the in between time
to set up her coming back
yeah yeah i'd be for it it's kind of
weird not seeing her this episode i mean
of course it's all gene but i think this
is uh aside from 5.0 back in season one
this is like the only other episode that
doesn't have kim in it so that's a
really interesting there i i wouldn't
mind seeing a lot more of her and where
she's at and how she might come back
into the story
yeah yeah that's what i was saying you
know in the beginning it is like a
season one um episode but it was it it's
without all of that wonder of like
having new characters and getting to
know them and everything i mean we do
have a couple new characters here
but these aren't these aren't people
we're expecting to you know
to be on you know to be on our side or
whatever you know the ones we're going
to root for these are the ones that are
going to cause problems for gene at the
end of the story
uh
oliver
thank you for the 499 do you think
there's a possibility of chuck still
alive at a random twist of fate perhaps
he married marion to get in contact with
jimmy
um
chuck is dead
maybe in an alternate multiverse
timeline
you know yeah he yeah he he's definitely
dead he didn't he adam you know this
season has had a lot of body doubles so
you know i can i get where you could
maybe uh you know
re you know go back and re-engineer that
that logic into that or something but
i don't believe chuck had a body double
i think that's his body they found
charred inside his
you know his house and um
if he comes back it'll be enough
as a ghost or a in a flashback
yeah
matt polikin thank you for the 9.99
gotta say i found myself bored with this
episode as weird as this sounds i
enjoyed the more mundane gene scenes
earlier in the season the old jeff was
much more menacing with the new jeff
was sad
yeah i mean
i don't i wouldn't say i ever felt bored
what i felt was
a crazy anticipation that had been built
up
and you know the the fact that
even though there's a lot of time left
you you're conscious of the fact that
the end is coming you know what i mean
like that's this is kind of what i think
about whenever
uh you know people were complaining you
know episodes four five and six
you know
i went back and re-watched those
recently and you know there's nothing
wrong with those episodes at all like
they're they're they're
they're really deliberate and
uh really well put together are they as
good as some of the other ones and you
know if you had to compare them no
definitely not
but they did what they had to do and the
payoff that came
because they were there
was as good as it was because of because
of what they set up so
i think even at that point it's like oh
well there's so much story to tell
there's so much story to tell
at this point where we're at now there
there isn't that much story to tell
you know we got an end for gus
we don't need to see anything else with
him we got an end for mike we don't need
to see anything else with him like it's
it's not hard to figure out in your mind
how they become the people that they are
whenever we see
breaking bad you know i mean that you
have the whole series of breaking bad to
you know rediscover that those
characters
could they show up again maybe you know
that it wouldn't be terrible there's no
problem with it i'm just saying that
there's no there's no hanging questions
that are essential to the the jimmy
mcgill story
that need to be answered there um
gene you know one of the big questions
was how will gene deal with this guy who
figured out who he was
in omaha
and that's what this answered you know
so the other big question then is
what does he do at the end and
what happens to kim and
that's really it so three three episodes
seems like like a luxurious amount of
time to answer those questions to me
yeah i definitely agree i'm not really
as stressed about them not having as
much time to you know finish the story
out as i may have a few episodes ago i
mean just finishing essentially
everything with better call saul and
episode 609 and having four extra
episodes i mean that's kind of crazy
right like i was expecting maybe one or
two gene episodes like two would be
crazy but the fact that we might get
maybe even three or even four
or two and a half or three and a half
depending how they break up the the walt
and jesse cameo um you know because we
we have seen the conclusion of
everything in the better cross hall
timeline you know nacho story's over
howard's story lalo's story you know
they're obviously all done for and then
we have the end of the cartel storyline
we put a bookend on that so we can see
how that you know transfers into the
breaking bad timeline uh gus and mike
talking about oh we gotta finish the
super lab that kind of alludes to uh you
know finishing off their arc and where
they're at and the way that uh gus and
mike looked at each other when mike was
about to uh go back through the tunnel
felt like a really nice end for those
characters i mean we even got the
conclusion to to mr varga right nacho's
father we even got that in there and
then obviously the the kim and jimmy
breakup scene explaining why they're not
together in future timelines and the
thing is is that i feel like a lot of
people expect it to be the ending to the
show to be all action in gunfights and
super high stakes and high high
intensity moments but
it seems like people keep wanting this
show to be breaking bad and that's just
not what it is like breaking bad is
is uh has always been on a larger scale
a more grandiose scale in regards to the
stakes and everything this show is more
of a uh as i mean breaking bad was
already a slow burn but this show even
more so it's more of a character study
you know it's it's it's a much more
character uh driven show and in that way
i i feel like the show is a lot more
relatable like this show occasionally
you know gets action heavy with with
bagman or with at the end of plan and
execution but at the core of it that's
not what better call saul is we we sure
kind of you know
swerve into that lane every once in a
while but j and the thing is is that
because we're winding down the show we
only have a few more episodes left
that definitely impacts how you view the
show
but once everything is said and done and
you can just enjoy it for what it is i
feel like once the pressure is off
there'll be a lot more appreciation for
for what they're doing here because uh
as i said earlier it's just the simple
fact that we've waited so long for this
gene episode uh but if let's say first
let's hypothetically if there's still
another season or two to go or if this
happened a season or two ago maybe if
this happened back in season five
there'd be a lot less pressure as like
oh well this is like one of the final
episodes yadda yadda i think you just
have to kind of take it at face value
and not put all of that pressure of uh
being one of the final episodes onto it
because i think it is great for what it
is and it stays true to what better call
saul is as a whole and i can really
appreciate the writers for doing that
and not sort of uh almost caving in and
putting in artificial action or tension
or stakes when it's not really even
necessary because this does really hit
home with gene and and it really does
match up with his uh mundane life so i i
definitely enjoy it i appreciate it and
um it's just interesting to see the
reception viewers have had with this
episode it's not always going to be you
know the action-packed face-off crawl
space that breaking bad is and i've
grown to appreciate that about this show
yeah i i you know like i said it wasn't
one that i had an enjoyable experience
with watching on the first thing i think
i've made that clear already like you
know
some of the reasons why
i mean i can understand if someone was
bored with it if they don't they don't
like that particular that particular
style of episode um
but as you said you know that is
something that's a staple of this series
i you know i saw a lot of comments
people saying it was the worst episode
of the of the series like i don't i
don't really get that at all um go go
watch koshata again and get back to me
you know i mean it's just sort of like
uh you know people have different tastes
it's okay uh if that's what their
takeaway was but
you know i i don't know what i i don't
know what the like story-wise i don't
know what what they're expecting you
know i see i've seen a lot of things
about like we need to see them build the
super lab and i i just think that is not
something that
that i feel like that would have been
annoying to me if we like spent a lot of
time on stuff that we know
already happens in in breaking bad you
know i mean i don't really see how that
that affects jimmy's storyline
at all and the story is about
jimmy and and kim and to a lesser extent
mike so
yeah and
and the thing about jeff um you know i i
did think that there was a noticeable
difference in the way that the character
was but i didn't i thought the the new
actor did a good job at the same time um
i kind of like in my head in my in my
head i kind of made it work out because
i thought you know it's because when we
see him at first he's he's on his own
and he's trying to act
cool in front of his friend and then
whenever
we see him at home
jimmy's already gotten in with his mom
and his mom is you know like around his
mom he's just a lot more uh
cowed you know what i mean
yeah
and there's like a weight of the whole
situation of like jesus this guy is
friends with my mom that's like the
worst thing i can imagine
i love how he sort of gave him a
checkmate there but at the same time uh
i i wonder what your uh opinion is on
the whole because because obviously you
know jeff got recast the original actor
couldn't make it because of another show
so they had to replace them and i feel
like they kind of catered the story to
this new actor's perspective and his
strengths and weaknesses so maybe that's
why jeff feels different just because of
the actor portraying him he did do a
good job but as far as like an in in
universe sort of canon even if it is
just a headcanon i wonder what your
opinion is on the fact that uh jeff
seemed more intimidating and ominous and
malicious because uh that's the way that
he initially perceived him uh due to his
paranoia and his anxiety and almost
having a panic attack through being made
but now that he's you know gotten in
with jeff's mother uh he perceives him
this way in this episode just because
he's not inten intimidating he's more of
kind of like a bumbling fool as i said
at the beginning of stream he seems a
bit more pathetic a little bit more
sympathetic um
and although i although i do really like
this jeff the whole time while watching
the episode i could not help but just
constantly think oh what would this look
like with the original actor how would
this feel if the original actor um
i i kind of kind of wish i could see
that version too uh sort of like a a
marvel multiverse uh what if crossover
um but i i do like what we're seeing
here with this jeff i just the whole
time i can't help but think oh what if
we had that other actor what would he
have looked like
yeah i think
i think part of the reason why i know i
liked how this guy uh
performed was because it only took a few
minutes for me to just totally forget
about that like i forgot i love dawn
harvey i re in those scenes i've
rewatched those scenes like hundreds of
times making videos and stuff like that
and you know
totally have a you know have a nostalgic
uh feeling about that but
this guy totally um brought me into that
you know this is the new jeff and i i
stopped thinking about the the whole
idea of it not too long into the episode
like by the time
you know g
yeah gene and his mom are
they're sipping snops and uh you know
he's sitting there looking broken and by
the time they go outside i was like yeah
okay this is jeff now you know what i
mean
definitely feels like
definitely feels like a different
character though um like if his name
just wasn't jeff and it was just someone
else like that that's kind of how i feel
about it like it is a little bit
disappointing that after all these years
of uh building up the original jeff from
season four and season five especially
how amazing don harvey did in season
five i was really looking forward to
that so it was a little bit
disappointing but that being said i
still enjoyed this version of jeff a lot
it just kind of felt like a different
character in a good way i still enjoyed
it but it's just the fact that i feel
like the original actor wouldn't have
played up sort of like the bumbling
buffoon sort of pathetic naive uh type
of i feel like the original jeff would
have been more intimidating so i'm still
interested on how that would have played
down but i do really like this jeff and
and at times i do really really uh
sympathize or empathize for him because
it seems like he just really wanted a
friend you know he's like come on we're
all friends here he's like no i'm not
your friend like stay away from me um
there's all the ruse
so i don't know makes me feel a little
bit bad for jeff which is something that
i never thought i'd say yeah
formula four four four eight eight eight
thank you for the 499 thoughts on where
kim is and if we'll ever see her again
she possibly in nebraska and same city
as jean
um yeah i do think we'll see her again
no i don't know where she's at
there's the idea that you know that like
it's possible she could be in nebraska
she is from there
i never really thought it made a lot of
sense for her to go back there on her
own um
they could come up with the reason for
that but i mean she ran away from there
we don't really know what she was
running from
uh but i mean you know it's a it's it's
sort of like 50 50. i mean a lot of
people think like why put them in
nebraska or why make her be you know
have her obviously they they made her
character after so why have her be from
the up from nebraska if it's not going
to somehow tie into what's going on with
gene
and i i just think that you know that
it's definitely
she's definitely going to we're going to
find out more about her we'll definitely
see her again as far as i'm concerned i
mean there's no confirmation of that at
all it's just it just seems
right to me but um
it feels a little contrived to me that
she might be in the same city
and they you know they just like
randomly come together after that
john baptist thank you for the five love
the streams the episode was amazing the
slip and subverted expectations with
false tension was amazing
very excited to see walt yeah i mean i i
think i i uh dm you
uh
after the episode like we usually do
chase and i think my first one said wtf
yeah and then we then we talked for a
little while and then i said you know
they did a great job of uh playing with
our expectations you know like i i was
like
like at the end of episode nine i felt
like
you know i i was in a different place
you know i mean like something had just
occurred and i was there as a witness to
it but
i didn't know how i felt about it you
know i mean it was just like so heavy
that it was taking a while to process
at the end of this one i felt like
you know surprised in a way and and
like i said i felt like that you know
that i had this expectation that wasn't
satisfied and then i had to decide how i
felt about that you know i mean i had to
process like well how does that make me
feel do i feel angry do i feel cheated
or do i feel wowed by the fact that they
were actually able to do that you know
and uh yeah it was funny it was funny
because you know i talked to you about
that and a couple other people and then
you know i made my video i talked about
how that you know they did a good job of
that and i thought about this like how
there was this sense of unease that i
had when i was watching it because i was
you know just not really sure
what you know it wasn't what i expected
and you know i listened to the insider
podcast last night when i was falling
asleep and um
she you know the
the writer was saying that they were
hoping to subvert expectations you know
what i mean and they were hoping
for people to feel a little
disillusioned and not really understand
why they made the choice so i was like
damn you know you really did a good job
with that
those are exactly the reactions that i
had you know
yeah exactly especially since for the
last like year and a half two years
we've been wondering what jeff's motives
are you know how malicious is he truly
i always kind of went down the alley of
he's gonna try and blackmail gene in
order to get him into the game
note i find it really funny how jeff
doesn't even know the phrase in the game
gene has to explain that to him
and um
i don't know i i really liked that uh it
subverted our expectations or at least
my expectations where i thought that the
whole time jeff was going to be
blackmailing gene but by the end of the
episode gene ends up blackmailing jeff
and
there's a lot that happened in this
episode that i did not expect like i
didn't expect gene and jeff to do a
scheme together i didn't i thought that
in in a way it was all part of gene's
plan where uh you know he set him up to
use it and you know to use it against
him and that's what the blackmailing is
but i always thought that gene would
just be working against jeff i didn't
think that they'd work together in the
way that they did i thought that was
interesting i like how they brought back
uh the guy that was with uh jeff in
season five and they kind of confirmed
that that's his brother and he's uh he
was the uh the delivery guy for the
shipment crate i i really like that and
um yeah i do think that i do think that
it subverted our expectations really
well um
just switch lanes uh just to talk about
the kim thing for a second from the last
super chat um
i in regards to kim being in nebraska uh
there's just two points i wanted to
touch on one is the fact that even
though at the end of uh 609 after the
breakup scene it kind of cuts for a
dramatic effect while uh kim is packing
up
you gotta assume that they had a few
more conversations after that before kim
was out of the apartment for good right
so jimmy probably knows wherever kim
moved to we don't as an audience but he
does and it's not like he has to hide
that because she didn't she didn't
disappear via edge she didn't change her
name she just moved away so i feel like
jimmy saljin knows where kim is and
in the breaking bad episode uh granite
state uh he
uh he says in nebraska what's in
nebraska so it's not i i don't think i
don't know because i i feel like you
know kim went back to her hometown she's
not far from home
uh people like to stick close to home
the cliche but at the same time like if
you had to put a gun to my head i would
guess that she went back home but at the
same time just the way that saul says oh
what's in nebraska or
it kind of seems like he's not he's not
and obviously that was written before
better call saul was created before
kim's character is created so they have
to sort of work around the confines that
breaking bad set up for them but with
that being said how are they going to do
it are they going to retcon that line
where
kim is in nebraska or kansas and uh gene
saul knows that or did he really not
think of her when in fact he could have
possibly been relocated really close to
her so i wonder if they're gonna address
that at all and if so how that's gonna
go down because that's kind of the only
uh pain in my side in regards to the
whole kim and jean reunion theory and
kim going back to her hometown is that
uh when saul got relocated to omaha it
sounded like there was nothing
anywhere nearby
for him there so i i wonder if you're
gonna address that
yeah i i don't know if i totally agree
with what you're saying i mean it's up
in the air it there's no way to know for
sure i don't know if i totally agree
with the idea that she would tell him
where she was going
because if they're if she's looking at
this like they're bad for each other
they're poisoned together and that the
only way that she can remedy that is to
leave
then then it's possible that she might
say you know what i'm not gonna tell you
where i'm gonna go because you're gonna
you're gonna eventually come after me
and uh that's not really gonna work you
know so i i i can see where you how you
arrived at that um because it's
completely up in the air i think i fall
on the other side of it though you know
that it's possible that he doesn't know
where she's at but he does know she's
from nebraska you know what i mean like
if there was a way to find her there you
would kind of think that she would and
it's kind of just
i kind of get tired of talking about
this in a way because it's just sort of
like it'll make sense when we get there
there's like so many things that
we could we could uh you know sort of
retread over and over but
um
we're almost there so like it's almost
like let's see what happens you know
yeah fair enough yeah i see where you're
coming from it does make sense that
maybe she wouldn't tell him i don't
necessarily think that kim thinks that
she needs to hide from jimmy or saul but
i mean it is possible
well one of the reasons why one of the
reasons i fall that way is because of
the phone call if she's the one who's
calling like why do they have to have
this crazy top secret phone call if he
knows where she's at anyways you know
what i mean
yeah that's a good point
but i mean that might not be her that
could be something different too you
know i mean exactly
that's why i do agree with you there's
so many different variables we can go
around in circles all day but we're
going to get the answer in a week or two
here so you know might as well just hit
tight
and for the end of this very excited to
see walt i am too i know it's like cool
to not want to see him but i i can't
wait till he comes on screen
that's his hands thank you for the 4.99
on the insider podcast today peter said
there is more jeff to come thoughts on
how jeff will continue to play a role
with gene
well i mean i think we talked about this
a little bit earlier maybe he weren't
here yet at his hands but i i feel like
the the real
i feel like the real
where there's real potential is with uh
marion more than g and more than jeff
himself um
i feel like there's a very very good
chance that marion
might
be
you know a more
a more reasonable
foe
you know someone who can actually
surprise jimmy he's already if that's
the case he's already underestimated her
he's already you know
kind of showed his uh
showed his way of operating you know i
mean he cut the co he cut the wires he
he fixed it it's all if if you're not if
you're paying attention if you're
looking for
suspicious uh
stuff in this in this random stranger's
house that you just brought in
it's all there to put together if you're
a little you know if you're uh if you're
if you're prone to think that way
yeah i think i think just for the simple
fact of you know the during the whole uh
gene blackmailing jeffsy and he he
drives at home that you know you know
don't talk to me don't come near me you
don't know me so i don't think that jeff
is going to go out of his way to try and
contact gene unless it's like some sort
of dire emergency so i think what's more
likely is we see jeff talk to marion and
then we see marion talk to gene somehow
whether she's relaying information from
jeffernaut or if jeff just kind of
motivates her to go talk to him for
whatever reason i feel like i feel like
marion would be the the middle man so to
speak between the two characters since
uh gene made it pretty clear that he
doesn't want anything to do with jeff
anymore
yeah she's the she's the i think that's
the way that that it comes back up
um
maria foreman thank you for the 4.99
love you guys and love bcs i'm from
omaha
just wanted to say all they talk about
here is husker football and they
certainly got that detail right
yeah yeah thanks for the the super chat
and um
i was wondering i was thinking about
this yesterday i i i drove
around the u.s quite a bit whenever
whenever i i lived there and um
i don't think i ever went through
nebraska at all i i i couldn't i
couldn't recall a time when i did that
um
but i do know that in in smaller
you know states that don't have big um
professional teams you know college
football pretty much seems to be like
the religion of the locals so
yeah what you're talking about there
i haven't been there myself but i did
get a youtube comment from someone that
said that they've lived there for about
a decade and they've been to that mall
plenty times and apparently the
actual store that's there is the macy's
i'm not i haven't fat checked it or
anything you know i haven't been there
to confirm but i thought that was real
interesting that there was a viewer of
mine who's who's uh so familiar to that
area that they could you know call up
the mall call out the exact store that
uh that that teaser trailer uh
of uh you know armani suits and run uh
was from so i found that really
interesting
well one of the probably the most
interesting well not maybe the most but
one of the most interesting things they
talked about on the insider podcast is
that none of the actual stores that are
open there would let them shoot
even at night so they had to go into an
empty one and build a completely
fictional you know like stock up a whole
department store with all their own
stuff and all their own people
to show wow
wow that's crazy yeah i've been
listening to the inside podcast i'm
going to later tonight but uh yeah
that's that's wow that's amazing yeah i
thought that was i thought that was
pretty impressive because even when you
go back and look i mean it looks like a
real place for sure
and that's not to say that that one with
the um escalator that shot that was in
the trailer that that could actually be
that's empty or whatever so that could
just be a real store but the ones where
jeff's running around
and we see like the other people the you
know the manager and stuff like that
that was all
a store that they built just for the
show
drakeris [ __ ] thank you for the 999 609
was the true finale of bcs where in the
epilogue episodes of bcs much like
granite state and felina were epilogue
episodes for the true climax finale of
ozymandias for breaking bad
love the episode yeah that's the old um
that's the old uh
that was the i remember that being a big
thing at the time i think
um uh who was the writer that
that wrote about that um
maybe
i don't want to get it wrong it might
have been emily nussbaum or one of those
people that was writing a lot about tv
back then
you know that she she talked about or
the writer talked about how
the season ended there i i think alan
seppenwall has also
you know talked about that
and i and i get it yeah i mean it makes
sense the the the the climax of the
story happens there and then
you find out what happens after and and
that's and it's kind of a strange thing
you know most tv shows um
might give you
a one episode after math kind of thing
and but not not this much story and even
you know with
with you know bcs we're getting even
more of that we're getting four full
episodes of epilogue if that's what it
turns out to be
i think it'll be a little bit different
though i think we'll see a little bit of
um
traveling through time you know going
back to
uh the the breaking bad timeline a
little bit and we'll we'll go to
different places we'll have gene but
then we could also have some kim and
then we could have them come back
together so yeah it's
you could call it an epilogue
i like to think of it as i i don't
really know what's going to happen the
next you know what's really going to
happen next and i like the feeling of
not knowing but um
we'll definitely see how it plays out
yeah i find i'm pleasantly pleased with
uh
or you know surprisingly pleased with uh
with how well they concluded all of the
stories right like something like nacho
in 603 i feel like most shows would have
saved that for like the final episode or
two but we got that three episodes into
the season and then we finished howard's
story and episode seven lala story in
episode eight and episode nine already
kind of felt like an epilogue and uh
with episode 10 being the full gene
episode i mean these are the full 10
normal episodes that we would have
gotten right now they did right this
season with the with the knowledge that
they had three bonus episodes so i'm not
saying that this would have been the
normal cutoff if they only had 10 but
just to think that this is the the
normal length of a season we still have
three bonus episodes in a way
or four including this one maybe even
five including 609 i just really enjoy
how they did that there and just uh
thinking that we have still have a few
more episodes so it just it just feels
like a lot of bonus content and i'm here
for it
yeah
tony grant thank you for the 4.99
another episode for the fans with a low
iq to hate on
hahaha
so um you're you're laughing at the end
so i i i'm thinking you're saying that
as you know with
a joking connotation yeah it was a joke
in connotation um
you know people like different things
i don't really feel like
i want to spend a lot of time trying to
convince people
like what they should like you know what
i mean it's sort of like there's there's
plenty of smart stuff that
i understand that it that why it's smart
and and that the you know the the
creator or the author is doing something
that
is impressive but i i still don't like
it you know i mean like there's
different
it's just not to my taste or whatever so
you know it's i don't think that
not enjoying what's going on here is is
a
there's a direct correlation to not
being able to understand it um you know
some people just like different things
yeah i mean like everything gets chalked
up to opinion right and i was uh i was
actually watching a ricky gervais uh
netflix comedy special earlier and i
kind of like what he said in regards to
he doesn't like it when people just say
that comedian's not funny it's like you
have to correct them well no you think
that comedian isn't funny or you found
this joke offensive so in a way you
didn't like the episode that doesn't
mean the episode's bad that doesn't mean
that other people aren't allowed to
enjoy it you know you enjoy what you
want and that's the thing it's all
chalked up to perspective and i mean
it's one thing if you're just gonna
blatantly hate on the episode for i mean
if you're just an action junkie i mean
that's just you that's not really what
the show is as i was saying earlier but
uh you know everyone's entitled to their
own opinion i just i i don't know i i
feel like constructive criticism is uh
is a lot better than just blatantly
hating something i found it funny sort
of the replies that tom schnauz was
giving on twitter to some blatant haters
where they actually just take the time
to tell them that they don't like the
show or they don't like the episode and
uh i don't know you just gotta shake
your head at that um you gotta take
everything with a grain of salt that's
that's how it is on the internet right
everyone's
there's always someone that's gonna be
like that so uh you just gotta enjoy
what you can enjoy and uh trying your
best to uh respect other people's
opinions as long as they're being
civilized about it
yeah it's subjective and uh jay thank
you for the two pounds
kim
kim jimmy's storyline to get wrapped up
in the breaking bad timeline
it doesn't seem likely but this is kind
of interesting you know that if they if
they showed us what's going on here
and then they flash back to breaking bad
they you know we got our walt and jesse
and we also got some sort of conclusion
to what's going on with kim
and why he you know why he's not looking
for her or why he he's
maybe there's a reason why he was able
to move on
as much as a person can
the only thing is like that that
telephone call always was kind of screws
up everything that that um
that it doesn't involve her coming back
later after he ran away but
you know it's possible they could do
that that would definitely cast this
whole situation that we're watching now
and you know that i think is going to
continue based on you know what they've
been saying and and what i'm seeing
it would it would cast it in a different
light
i mean this shows really good with
subverting my expectations so i won't
put anything past them i feel like it's
more likely to see kim in the gene
timeline but we do have to jump back at
some point to see walt and jesse so who
knows they could tackle kim while
they're doing that then we could jump
back forward to see gene i feel like
that might be what that time machine
book was uh sort of implying is that
we'd be jumping back and forth uh
through time and it wouldn't just be one
chronological linear line like uh like i
might have originally thought so i'm
here for it i i'm open to all
possibilities and as i said the show's
subverted my expectations many many
times and they've done it in uh
brilliant ways so if if they're gonna do
it they're gonna do it well and uh yeah
there's just so many variables we'll
just have to wait and see
yeah here's another interesting one
almeida's army two pound this takes
place october 10th
the call p takes place november 10th i
thought the call was november 12th i
thought it was a birthday but it's it's
not really important
yeah whenever you bring this up that
does sound kind of important that it's
only a month away um
that you know that would be
that would be
the first call that he got since he left
and the first time that he's been out
here
in a different situation so that's
interesting i didn't think about that at
all until right this minute
i i saw i saw a theory i don't remember
if it was on twitter in the youtube
comments but someone said that the phone
call could just be jimmy himself talking
to francesca
um and maybe that's why francesca sounds
so displeased about you know having to
take the call just because she always
scoffs at jimmy like and at the end of
609 after him yammering in her
ear all morning he sits down at his
office at his desk and pages her and
she's like
what so you know she's always had that
attitude towards saul so i think i think
if it actually just is jimmy needing to
call francesca for whatever reason on
her on his birthday that that would
explain why frances francesca is so
eye-rolling you know about it
so to speak i thought he i thought he
says though they'll call
like not i'll call he says they'll they
will or something like that
i i don't know i'd have to go and see
the scene again i think he said
something on the lines of uh if it
doesn't ring i'm leaving he's like don't
worry it'll ring so i'm not sure oh yeah
you might be right yeah i might just i
might have just did that i mean i think
that would to me that would feel like a
little bit of a retcon if if he's just
if he's just talking about himself
there's there's less mysterious ways
that he could have got that across um
but you know we'll see
i i i you know you brought that up and
it's something that i've been thinking
about
and it's another one of the reasons why
this this episode kind of felt so
disorienting is because i keep having
all these revelations about
saul and about the you know the original
series and about everything that's going
on after the information that we got in
in
uh episode nine
and that was one of the things i was
thinking about um
francesca you know you're thinking like
how did she go from such a nice happy
person
to this you know just where she's just
completely over it for pretty much the
whole situation while she's in in
breaking bad and and if you had to
listen to if you had to be the one
person that saul called 24 hours a day
and because he can't he can't let
himself think his own thoughts for like
one minute you know i mean so he's just
constantly going i mean it's exhausting
right
yeah i'd get jaded pretty quickly too if
i was her yeah her transformation makes
perfect sense
yeah nathan nathan m thank you for the
499.
robert gay thank you for the 499. before
season six saw gene in albuquerque with
wanted posters end of 610 he leaves
behind saul close is jimmy ready to face
the world as himself maybe turn himself
in
that was not my take at the end of the
episode um
i mean i i get what you're saying about
hanging up the clothes
that was sort of a snag in the process
but
i didn't think that showing him getting
away clean
really moved him anywhere closer to
turning himself in he had a problem
he had to think on his feet
he handled it you know at least for the
time being so like i i didn't think that
it did actually move him anywhere closer
to turning himself in did you what did
you think
i mean i i think that it shows that uh
you know symbolically saw goodman
slipping jimmy is always gonna be a part
of him it's always something deep down
inside of him and no matter how much he
tries to hide it or bottle it up it's
gonna come out eventually i don't think
he's gonna fully revert into one or the
other um i know the all of the season
six promos have implied that uh gene is
going to turn back into saul or
something like that but i think that
he's going to turn into uh almost a new
version of himself that is a combination
of all three personas and i do love the
symbolism though where he he
sort of looks at himself in the mirror
with that shirt on him or you know
holding it up to him and it's almost
like he's proud of himself uh for
for who he used to be and how he can
still flip that switch when he needs to
but he puts the shirt down because he's
not quite ready or doesn't want to just
entirely revert back to it so i feel
like it's always a part of him and he's
proud of himself for it and it's always
there but he doesn't necessarily need to
you know fully turn back into that i
feel like he is uh pursuing his uh i
feel like he's pursuing a new path
almost that's the way that i interpreted
it
yeah so the question that this guy has
is do you think he's he's ready to turn
himself in and that's a no right
yeah no i i don't think that that that's
not what i got from that i mean it's
always been a huge theory of mine to uh
theorize about gene going to jail and
turning himself in yada yada being a
criminal prison lawyer but uh that's
definitely not the interpretation that i
got from that final scene in the episode
yeah i mean i i definitely think that
that's what's gonna happen i think he's
gonna have to reckon with you know some
of what what he's done and and you know
kind of
look at and live with some of the stuff
that he's compartmentalized away and
that you know he's he's refused to look
at
and i think that turning himself in
would be a great way to do that but i i
didn't think that this moved him closer
to that you know like you're saying i
thought that there was a there was a
there was a uh you know there was a
he had he he he had his moment he got
away with it
um at least right now and uh
what can you say you know i mean like
what what
what problem arose in that that would
you know that he would need to
um give up his freedom to solve i don't
see it yet
that's why i kind of think marion it
might might be there might be more to
the character of marion um doug davis
two dollars jeff would outsolve for
immunity bad writing in my opinion
yeah maybe um i don't think that they
they portrayed jeff as being a
really smart and uh
you know
together guy that might might know that
but um he's a bit of a doofus he seems
like someone that would be easy to fool
kind of in the same way how in season
three uh jimmy fooled his uh community
service supervisor with the threat of uh
suing him you know uh it's just it's
just about the way that they're making
him uh that they're that he's trying to
intimidate this person in order to get
what he wants and in that case it
definitely works i don't really think
that he's gonna think of the logistics
of it too much i feel like he's gonna be
too struck and by what gene told him to
really do anything about it or pursue it
any further i think it kind of just
stopped him in in his tracks um whereas
someone else may may go down that route
i think i think that uh i think that he
uh convinced jeff pretty well to sort of
stay in his own lane
yeah and then you know there may be
there may be more to it too like you
know he said it felt like an ending but
three more episodes to go it probably
isn't
nathan m thank you for the 199 can you
hear about theorize about the 11 12 3
p.m phone call yeah we were just talking
about this so um
i don't really have any more to add at
this time but you know it is interesting
that it's that's coming up in in the
show's uh timeline and and not too long
from
i don't know how much time passed during
the scam uh there was definitely weeks i
think you know that was my impression
because they talked about different
football games i think and those only
happen once a week so
i was paying a lot of attention to some
of the details but i didn't i didn't go
back and like try to actually say well
they were doing this for three weeks or
something like that or there was a week
or two after they mentioned the thing
you know what i mean so
i'm not 100 on that but
it's around the corner this 11 12 3 p.m
phone call is around the
corner quas forbe thank you for the 999.
based on the date of this episode the
november call to francesca the only real
mystery left to answer
is near yeah well i don't know if it's
the only mystery um where kim is and how
her story ends i think is is
a pretty big one but that is probably
also tied to this
uh question or to this call so yeah we
just were talking about it and and i
agree with you there quas4 but that it's
around the corner it's near
thank you for the super chat
uh we got a super sticker 4.99 thank you
marcus trione
don't see too many of those so that's
cool thank you very much um
ruses thank you for the 199 when do you
think walt and jesse will appear
i i thought they were going to appear
this week
so now i think they're gonna appear next
week uh but i don't have any
reason i don't i can't explain why other
than it's been announced that they're
gonna show up you know i really don't
none of this nothing that happened in
this episode
changed anything
as far as what i understand about their
appearance
did you pick up anything new that might
inform that
uh the only thing new that i picked up
is to take those uh
article interviews with it with a grain
of salt uh as far as there as far as
their confirmations go because yeah yeah
i'm in the same boat oh they're gonna
appear this week oh no okay they didn't
oh they're gonna appear next week oh no
no they don't uh so so
that's gonna be me as sort of a broken
record until they finally do appear it
just really depends uh
depends the way that they wrote it you
know how much are we gonna spend with
gene when are we gonna jump back they
could equally do it at any episode uh
when they first announced the walton
jesse cameos i assumed like before
season six even started i assumed it'd
be in the very last episode uh but then
we started getting hints that they might
appear sooner than them and as we all
know imdb isn't really a reliable source
for something before the actual episode
comes out so we'll just have to wait and
see honestly
yes my echo my shadow of me thank you
for the 199. what could marion even do
gene neutralized jeff
uh
well i think that
if she is if there's more to her story
if there's more to who she is
she may have other ways to get to him i
i you know i can't really say other than
i mean they didn't show anything here so
i can't like say oh well
this when she did this i was sure that
this is gonna happen next but
i can imagine that they could they could
come up with a way that
she could make things very complicated
for him and and i mean she's
i don't know carol burnett's close to 90
in real life i don't know if the if the
character is supposed to be at that same
age
but she could be definitely like that
could be the angle of her being like i i
don't i don't care you can't you can't
do anything to me you know i'm at the
end of my life uh
you could try to take me down with you
or whatever it doesn't matter
um
or she could just she could have you
know she she mentioned she name-checked
albuquerque and him falling in with
people
there might be more to
you know what she knows and what and you
know it's just hard to say
it's it's it's like fascinatingly wide
open you know it's great
i mean definitely definitely don't
underestimate your elders you know
they've they've been through it and it
seems like marion stills has her wits
about her i do like the idea of sort of
uh kind of like a parallel to carol in
the walking dead where she puts up this
facade of i'm this sweet lady that bakes
cookies but when it comes down to it
she's like an incredibly abrasive badass
so i i would like to see that uh that
other side to marion if if if uh if that
exists
yeah
richard genbrin thank you for the 199.
jeffy jeff equals cliff bane's son
thought
i'm a little bit exhausted with the i i
still find it funny that you know uh
every post that i see
about better call saul anywhere has a
mention of cliff main sun in it but um
i'd be pretty shocked if if jeff was
his actual son
yeah that cliff main sun thing is kind
of the new uh kim is wendy uh meme
in my opinion
joe figueroa thank you for the five
dollars kiwi everyone wants to see your
face uh that's a personal choice so
yeah maybe one day today's not that
today's not the day though
yeah i i did see some people saying that
but if i was in your position and i was
reading that i'd be like no i'm not
gonna do it because you tell me to do it
you know what i mean
like if they were asking like or they
were you know they were bringing
something to it other than just
demanding that you uh do that i mean
depending on how your setup is you know
and everything else it can be a little
bit of a pain in the ass to
to do that you know i mean i worked on a
laptop for years it would have been you
know it would have been like crappy
webcam and
um
yeah yeah i got a i got an msi laptop
with a built-in webcam i mean it just
adds another element to uh content
creation right because if you don't have
your camera on you can just kind of sit
there read off your notes and you don't
you don't have to worry about looking
entertaining at the same time as you
sound entertaining like if you
uh let's say you record a bunch of
videos out once you you know i know
people
get a hard time for always wearing the
same shirt because they record a bunch
of videos at once or always having to
wear a different setup i don't really
have a an actual like you know setup
behind me i don't have a set or anything
like that it just adds another element
to video creation uh and you it just uh
content creation already takes
already takes up so much time um
that and plus i'm i'm also more
old-fashioned in regards to uh content
creation i mean i used to do gaming
videos like a decade ago back before
face cams were the norm like on twitch
like every streamer has a face cam like
if i ever did live stream video games or
something like that like i probably
wouldn't have i mean i might have a face
cam um i'm not necessarily against it
it's just not really not really for me
not something not really an element i've
ever uh considered uh imp or
implementing into my uh video creation
process it just adds a another layer on
top of it
yeah
yeah it's not it's i tell everyone that
i invite on it's not you know it's not
compulsive so whatever it's it's
whatever they choose i like to i don't
really care to do it myself but i like
that there's some some moving pictures
going on that at least a few of us have
something going there because otherwise
it's it's pretty static and
i'm not sure why why it's on youtube
instead of just making a podcast or
something but
it's not important blake lindsey thanks
for the five he's he's asking a question
that i've seen a couple of other times
and and i think that it's not
necessarily true um i watched the vanity
fair thing with bob odenkirk and ray
seahorn and they confirmed that jesse
and walt will be in multiple episodes
i watched the same thing and that wasn't
my takeaway uh my takeaway confirmed
that
sorry for you yeah my takeaway was is
yeah but i i you saw it too you're
actually one of the people i got a
couple people sent it to me and you were
one of them
um the
they they come they said that
they were going to show up in the next
six episodes because it was recorded you
know in the mid-season break or whatever
but yeah i didn't catch anything that
said that they would be
involved in multiple episodes just that
that you know they would be coming
and the ones to come
i think bob said something along the
lines of we'll see them multiple times
and that's very similar to what he said
back at the tribeca uh screening where
he said that we don't see them just once
and with walter with brian cranston
confirming that we have one walt scene
one jesse scene and then one scene with
them both together i think that's what
they're talking about whether or not
we're gonna see all three scenes in the
same episode or if it's gonna be spread
across the three final episodes i'm not
sure for all we know the next three
episodes we could have a cold open of
each scene and then cut back to gene i'm
not sure um i always figured we'd get
all three in the same episode but you
know again it's just
really you know up to up to how they
created it uh i'm neither here nor there
in regards to getting them all in the
same episode or spanned across the final
three because regardless of if they're
back to back to back it's the same
amount of time with them and i don't
really think it impacts uh when or how
we see it to be honest
yeah i think there'll be something to it
i think there'll be some substance there
something that you know
that guides what jimmy does in the
future but i i don't know it it doesn't
really
i don't see yeah like how you said i
don't think it really makes a difference
if it's in one episode or more
seth r paid two dollars and thank you
for that to tell kiwi he isn't saying
marion correctly
i didn't i didn't pick up on it so i
don't know
marion marion marion
marion macaroon i think i'm just gonna
say it a different way every time now on
purpose
zh thank you for the five dollars sons
talk to mothers
and saw a story about the teacher with a
pile of money made national news
i think marion can add uh yeah that's
what i was saying you know like this
could be this could have you know
walter white recently died there is this
thing
this american greed thing that might
exist in their universe um
that could come out that's a potential
thing that happened i think um courtney
mentioned that when i was talking to her
yesterday um
that made some sense you know i i saw
that and i and i watched it a couple
times but i can't remember
how long after that they're talking
about
whenever they they made that so i don't
know how it fits chronologically but
um yeah there's definitely ways like you
know not only does the sons talk to
mothers but she feels like she you know
she's she's kind of in control of what
he does and and and
and being you know like
she feels like she's the reason why he's
there and and she brought up this idea
of gene being a good influence and part
of the reason why he's doing so much
better here you know it all sounds like
you know she could definitely know more
than she's letting on
in regards to the american greed i just
find it interesting how it sort of that
video ended as if they were going to
commercial break as if there was going
to be more afterwards so
a theory that i always had is that once
season six is over maybe we'll see an
american greed part two i don't know how
realistic it is
uh that
uh they're going to do that or if they
already filmed a part two and they're
just waiting to release it or what the
deal is but that was always my takeaway
that uh and maybe that's just the way
that they ended the video you know they
ended the video by making it seem like
they're going to commercial maybe they
come back and do a different segment on
a different person but uh yeah i always
wonder if we're going to get an american
greed part two after the events of
of season six it's almost like they went
to commercial break to wait to show us
the rest because they obviously didn't
want to spoil what happens in season six
yeah
they definitely did it like an actual
episode of um
american greed which is something that
i used to watch sometimes you know like
in the background
it was like straight up like you know
the first sequence to the commercial
break you know i mean they didn't they
didn't change it at all to make it fit
to like what they were trying to do
there so it's possible that there's a
whole episode that exists joe figueroa
thank you for the five why do i feel
like jeffy is related to kim
i'm not sure joe
i didn't pick up on any of that but
it's not impossible
it would be it would feel a little bit
um
a little bit contrived i think but
they they do those kinds of things
sometimes and they seem to they seem to
mostly work you know there are
coincidences in this universe
i i just i just find it really
interesting that jeffy was actually
related to macaroon because i thought
that i thought it was going to be
something other than that i i initially
wondered if uh
if uh
if marion was going to be related to kim
or something like that or had to
disappear his wife and i i'd really like
how they subverted our expectations with
making uh marion um
related to uh jeff i found that uh
because in the uh in the recent
interview with bob and ray they said uh
like bob confirmed that uh
marion's uh related to someone but we'd
never guess and it was it was right
under our nose the whole time i find it
wild how uh how that wasn't really i
mean some people predicted it uh but i
just find it wild how that wasn't a more
popular theory and i think they did it
great
yeah that was my favorite theory and
then i thought that it was it was gonna
be different because of of that uh
in the saturday stream someone mentioned
the the the spanish language um
thing that was out there and i went to
reddit and found that and it sounded
like maybe she was his neighbor not his
not jeff's
mom or whatever but
i don't know how i don't think i would
have ever got to the she's jeff's mom
um i mean i might have
you know but that was something that i
heard from you know just it was bouncing
around the internet and then i thought
oh that that would be kind of cool i
kind of thought maybe she would be sick
or something so it would be like a point
of being sympathetic um
you know i mean or you know to where he
was like oh well i don't want to really
break this guy down because he's got all
this other stuff going on but the way it
played out it you know it makes sense to
me that she could be
she could be a secret weapon waiting to
waiting to uh come against
gene takavik because he just looks so uh
he just looked like he was getting away
so scot-free at the end of the last
episode
i just find i just find it i just find
it interesting how uh how seamlessly uh
macaroon was implemented into the into
the gene timeline because we didn't know
if uh she was going to be in the gene
timeline or the breaking bad timeline or
when exactly uh she was going to pop up
but i think she did really well here i
think it fits perfectly honestly
yeah it's one of those things where i i
didn't like a lot of the popular
theories and and that's sort of why i
like this one i didn't really know how
it was going to turn out but i like this
one better than her being like howard's
mom or
kim's mom you know
and uh yeah i was i was impressed with
the way it turned out mostly love of
music thank you for the 10 pounds was it
ever realistic for jeff to run multiple
times to collect three times 20 items
including tag removals all in just three
minutes the escalator is certainly not
modeled in gene's snowy practice course
yeah i think there's a little bit of
suspension of disbelief um
it makes it's something that makes for a
fun episode you know watching him run
around and having this
this plan i mean whenever he's
you know we obviously had a little bit
of an idea that he was going to be
yelling this stuff but i mean nobody i
don't think anybody said oh they're
practicing you know
from this store stealing expensive items
from this store and they're practicing
it out in a snowy field that they
recreated to make it you know exactly
like the place that they're going to rob
you know i i think that chris mccaleb
said on the insider podcast that for
them to actually do it for for jeff
healy to actually do it it takes about
12 minutes
you know to grab all the things that are
on the list so it doesn't actually
really work out in real life but
they had to shoot it like it you know to
make it look like it was going to be
three minutes and that that's pretty
complicated when you think about it you
know what i mean because they have to
sort of sync it all up and and make it
look exciting on the screen
um
yeah so yeah you know maybe not so
realistic but
fun as hell to watch i thought
definitely definitely some creative
liberty some suspension and disbelief
but i still liked it i thought it was
original it was interesting to watch i
really love the way that uh i did i just
i don't know i love the cadence that
gene has that bob owen kirk has when
he's listing off all of the all the air
jordan shoes for you and and all of that
i i don't know i just find myself
listening to that part over and over
again it's just uh one of those oddly
satisfying things then hearing jeff kind
of in a huff uh repeating it to himself
as sort of a catchy way to remember what
he's doing and to motivate himself while
he's going throughout the con i i really
like that touch i i enjoyed the dialogue
ever since the teaser trailer but seeing
it come to fruition in the actual
episode was it was very satisfying for
me i really liked it
yeah
asan k
isan
se
thank you for the five dollars canadian
as jeff slips slip and jimmy goes into
survival mode sort of begging to save
his own life in desperation
do you think that was the case
well i mean you know it that seems funny
and and it kind of almost undermines the
stakes because
he is like you said going into survival
mode here if he if if his identity comes
out if he gets arrested and
fingerprinted and all that kind of stuff
his life is kind of over you know what i
mean so um
yeah i would say that that was the case
that he goes into survival mode and um
you know we talked about it a little bit
earlier about you know how he pulls on
you know he pulls out these true things
and i thought that you know
his parent he says his parents are dead
it doesn't really
it doesn't really
feel like he's you know he's obviously
sobbing he's making it up but it feels
like he's acting there and then they
they had this decision to have him wait
just to you know just a second before he
says his brother's dead
that really gives that line
some weight and you know and i i don't
know i i think he you know he is just
play acting there
there's the scene afterwards where he
goes outside and he's sort of
catching his breath and he looks like
he's you know freaked out by it i don't
think he's really reacting to to
bringing up chuck there necessarily i
think it's the actual tension you know
the that of watching
him laying there i mean they set it up
to where they show that every single
time when he takes that last bite he
turns around you know i mean so it
he's watched this so many times he knows
what's going to happen if his little
distraction doesn't work and i thought
it was super funny that he actually says
no look at me at one point you know what
i mean yes
he just said it out loud because you
know like it's that it's that intense
and um
but i do you know i i can't i can't i
have to imagine maybe he thought about
chuck again later you know what i mean
um
maybe that brought something up in him
that that he hadn't looked at for some
time you know we'll have to wait and see
on that one
yeah i feel like that moment where he
brought up his brother was one of the
only real moments out of all of that as
chuck would say it was play acting it
was theater um for the most part i do
find it funny how he just directly hits
it on the nose and it's like no look at
me i find that really funny
it was a great moment it's just just
trying to try to grasp at straws and say
anything you can right
yeah i i i caught that on the first
watch but i didn't appreciate it until
the second watch and
there's so much stuff and and i didn't
really in in the video i made i didn't
really
uh get to talk about how how good um
jim o'hare is as as frank here the night
security guard like there's so many just
you know i mean he doesn't have a lot to
do but everything that he did here he
really just uh you know he just over
delivered you know he really made that
character uh something something great
to watch
cp show thank you for the ten dollars i
think marion finds out genus saul i
believe she has new mexico ties
my big theory i think that kim is
pregnant when she leaves jimmy
and episode 11 is a kim episode that
picks up where they left the
breakup yeah i mean these are things
that we talked about um
on saturday
and um when we were talking about this
episode i think that there is a
possibility that that kim that there
will be like a lot more kim and and
that's what i thought going into this
episode and after seeing that jeff is is
almost essentially neutralized or
whatever that problem has dealt with
at least for the time being it made me
think that there's a lot there's a lot
more of a chance of of us seeing more
kim
solo scenes you know wherever she is
i don't know that um
it's possible i just mentioned this to
chase a second ago about like she she
could have some connection to to new
mexico
since she does name check albuquerque
but
i don't think it's a given necessarily
um
the pregnancy thing that's something
that um
that's something that courtney brought
up when we were talking after episode
nine and i thought
it didn't it didn't seem like a natural
it didn't feel like it it fit for me at
that time like that was my my you know
my initial take
they can make it work i think um
it makes things a lot more complicated
so it would just depend just depend on
how they handled it it's not something
that i'm drawn to of like oh that would
be an interesting twist um i think it
would work
um
but i don't know what are you what are
your thoughts on on kim being pregnant
chase uh i i never really considered to
be honest i i feel that to be kind of
out of left field um kind of in the same
sense of the whole cliche of when they
finally reunite she's in love with
someone else and she has a kid with them
or or something like that uh
i i don't really think that uh kim would
just
i don't know i don't know because well
now that i'm thinking about it i'm kind
of changing my mind like hypothetically
if that were true i could see kim
leaving because she doesn't want uh that
conning like to bring up a child in that
conning life and to be that what they
grow up around uh that sort of toxic
environment so i could see it from that
perspective but that was never really
something that crossed my mind and uh i
don't think it's uh very likely to uh to
see to be honest
yeah i mean it could work like i said
and you know that was my first thing was
it's kind of a betrayal if she if she
leaves and she doesn't tell him about it
but i think the response there is that
um
you know he's
she's doing it to protect the child you
know like you were saying there so if
that would be the case then
it's understandable but um
i don't know we'll have to see like i
said i just i could see it happening but
i don't i don't love it i'm not like oh
yes that that that makes it all come
into you know into focus for me or
something like that
i think there's enough to send her away
without that happening i guess is what
i'm saying you know if she if she has
this she has this realization that
this is an addiction it's always going
to progress it's always going to get
worse even if howard didn't die here
eventually there's going to be other
unintended consequences
in order to keep it going they have to
keep scamming because they you know
they're chasing the dragon as it were
you know what i mean like there's enough
there that she can leave i don't i don't
really need her to be pregnant for that
to happen
my echo my shadow and me thank you for
the 4.99 again uh after all the teaser
misdirection maybe it it actually is kim
at the stop sign
the obvious guess
showing their hand would subvert our
expectations
um
yeah
i think that's uh
you're talking about the one the post
credits teaser this week i haven't
really gone back and looked at look at
looked at that yet um
i watched it exactly once uh whenever
the the episode ended
and i thought that's yeah i thought that
that's what they were teasing is that
could this be kim could they be going
back to albuquerque but um
unfortunately i meant to look at that
this morning and i never got around to
it um
and that would come back to the
that's what my thought has been about
him turning himself in at the end of the
season is that they could have just
showed us that in the very you know that
one teaser where we see him go back that
like where we literally go to see him
and go back to albuquerque as gene um
and they're beginning of the season
i wouldn't put it past them
marcus trione thank you for the five i
think it's an issue that he answered the
call from the department store manager
as steve
but his cinnabon co-worker called him
gene she must have heard um
i didn't i i didn't necessarily think
that would be the case i did think that
they emphasized this character a little
bit so i wouldn't be surprised if she
comes back into things um
i i just don't know
he you know she called on the cell phone
he did mention she
he was interrupted but i don't know you
could say for sure that that he um that
she heard that because she she went
along with what what he wanted like it
to me it seemed like my take on it was
is that
he was able to win her over
um could that end up being you know
something that comes up again later if
she figures it out you know
i think that's an interesting tidbit i
didn't really consider that when i was
watching the episode i mean the name
steve and jean are fairly similar so if
she did hear something it could have
been muffled from across the room so uh
who knows if she distinctively heard
that um
it obviously didn't really come back and
uh
when uh when gene goes into the store
afterwards i mean i guess it was jeff
that was the one that actually talked to
her but uh he doesn't really seem to be
too concerned about uh being made in
that regard
yeah
um
i agree uh bk tad thank you for the five
maybe a situation where 611 is a gene
timeline
and ending in a cliffhanger decision
to go to albuquerque
then 612 in breaking bad timeline
then 613 back to gene yeah i think we
were just talking about this a little
bit ago and i do think that there's a
there's a high potential chase said the
same thing of them jumping around
um
it's hard to imagine him making the
decision in 611
without something
you know without without some kind of
big intervention but
you know they could get there they could
definitely get there
yeah i mean it seems like an interesting
theory i don't really have anything to
refute it but at the same time i'm as i
said earlier i'm neither here nor there
in regards to when and how and and yeah
i do agree that if gene goes back to
albuquerque there has to be some huge
driving force that either makes him skip
town of omaha or along with some sort of
reason to actually go back there whether
he does eventually want to turn himself
in or for some other reason there
definitely has to be a huge driving
force or revelation or
truth bomb that he has to uh go through
in order to come to that conclusion
yeah
um
yeah so i wanted to
it looks like we're about an hour behind
as far as um
get into these questions so oh my gosh
yeah so i think there's probably quite a
few of them still
let's say we're about one hour 40 uh i
imagine we're gonna go a little bit
later so if we get to two hours and
or a bit longer and you need to take off
just let me know
i i will
for me personally i'll stay and answer
them all but um
you mentioned earlier that you might
have to go and i do want to thank
the moderators we had some people
volunteer
this week and when i when i asked on
saturday and i really appreciate that um
i one i
won
scott
newsom i think was the name i'm kind of
uh
stumbling around in a couple of
different tabs here uh
where are we at
yes scott newhouse i'm sorry uh he has a
small channel he wanted me to mention
that and
you know
after he said he would volunteer and i
appreciate that and i think you should
check out his channel
hopefully he can slap a link there for
you for you to check it out because i'm
like an hour behind in the in the
the stream so
radio chaos thank you for the 5 canadian
can't wait to see which episode they
address the call on jimmy's birthday
it's on everybody's mind
more and more people are saying it
like i wasn't thinking about that at all
whenever i was trying to put the thing
together but after this stream
it really is uh it really is a big
question isn't it
yeah
randy soya matsu thank you for the 199.
thanks to you two and others for making
things fun
thank you
thank you for saying that and thank you
for making it fun too randy
yeah thanks for joining us chad is what
it's all about you know wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for you guys so appreciate
having back and forth conversation
between all the different better call
saul viewers it's always a good time
yeah yeah it's it blows my mind how many
questions we get and it's it is a lot of
fun to
interact in that way mr g thank you for
the 199 ray talked like she worked with
burnett
in interview
hmm
oh it's like she had a scene with her or
something
ah
i didn't catch that
did you catch that
no i didn't i mean uh no i'd i'd have to
go watch the uh i'd have to go watch the
video again to be honest
yeah
that's interesting mr g uh although i
didn't catch it so i don't know what to
say about it if she did say that
um
yeah then the worlds are gonna collide
marion will probably come back and kim
will probably come back because i don't
think they're going to do you know
something tricky there with those two
unless it i mean they could meet in the
breaking bad timeline but that would be
that would be a complete that would be a
complete shock
i don't know i have no idea
two people that aren't you'd have to put
two people who aren't in
albuquerque together in albuquerque or
put them
together in nebraska and then make it
all make sense for how gene met the
other one the second one after her son
randomly picked her picked him up at the
hospital
i have absolutely no idea how
kim could possibly
meet uh mario over there but i do gotta
say that if macaroon and kim had a scene
together that it would be really
interesting especially if they're sort
of like playing mind games back and
forth with this uh sort of inherent like
they're they're being nice on the
surface level but they're kind of
throwing shade back and forth playing
mind games uh 4d chess so to speak i
think that'd be really interesting but i
don't i don't think we're going to see
it i have no idea how that could
potentially happen
yeah i was i was saying how i thought
that she could be a formidable foe for
for gene um
i hadn't even thought about
how that would you know
kim kim coming to the rescue in that
situation would be a lot of fun to watch
jack g79 thank you for the five dollars
did you see the cheese marion8 said
schnoz farms
as a nod to the resident bcs
breaking bad genius tom
wisconsin can keep that hilarious yeah i
i noticed this on the very first watch
um
it's pretty conspicuous there
i can imagine people missing it at the
same time though and i saw that there
was a a post about this on twitter after
um
you know that he he said that it was you
know his his cheese or whatever um
yeah you know it's a really distinct
name he's one of my favorite characters
in the the writer's room to think about
um i i don't know i uh eric who comes on
here did an interview with him
on his channel that i watched a while
ago
and um
i've you know inside the gila verse and
it was before he was his co-host or
whatever and i i he mentioned that they
that he knew vince back in film school
and i just thought that was such an
interesting story you know the way that
they they worked together on the
different shows
and uh you know they knew each other
from a time when neither one of them had
anything going on
big fan of tom schnauz for sure i love
how how crude and abrasive he can be
with his funny sense of humor he's
always he's always a laugh right
whenever he's on the uh the gila verse
or the insider podcast just the way he
throws punches i i think it's great a
big fan of him for sure
yeah
yeah and he and he's he uh
he's he's he answers a lot of questions
sometimes you know i mean he he
definitely um
contributes to the conversation around
the show and and i'm i'm happy that he
does that too
ali oliver
199 i'm beginning to think that these
questions aren't entirely serious um oh
no
i'll still read them anyways chuck
buried ernie's body
he's finna come back
i always want to see the return of ernie
i doubt it's going to happen
uh but i always wanted to see it
yeah you know i i mentioned that in my
last video that i was that i was you
know i said hey ernie's the actor who
plays ernie must not have been available
and some people gave me comments you
know like oh ernie would never go back
to hhm they they treated him terribly
but i mean
my my mind you know he he what he left
he prospered
and you know
he looks back on that time as something
that he did in his past life almost so
of course he would show up at hhm
and um
pay respects because he's moved on and
you know he's doing he's got his own
thing going on where he doesn't really
care about the little setback of working
at hhm back in the day
my uh my head cannon is that he's
working over there at davison maine with
elmar and they're just having the time
of their lives
yeah davis maine would be a good place i
mean that was a
it was comically
it was a comically great place to work
you know what i mean like it was almost
like they were joking like look what how
could we make this just such a great
place to work that it would make you
completely
question jimmy's uh you know what's
wrong with him that he can't make this
work you know what i mean
i think you said the last stream uh
cliff just always tries so hard to be
just such a good guy right
mm-hmm
yeah he's uh he's he's one of the best
in the universe and um you know
one of the one of my favorite parts of
his story was always that
you know jimmy's doing all this
ridiculous stuff and he thinks
you know that cliff doesn't know what's
going on so whenever they have their
little showdown and he's like
i know what you're trying to do you're
trying to get your thing you know i
always loved that that was a great turn
for the actor
that was a great a a ron
thank you for the 20 that is very
generous i read the ending i read the
ending of the episode that gene putting
the shirt back on the rack is him
literally hanging up his sole persona
for good
the teaser for next week epis next
week's episode hints that gene will
return to albuquerque
yeah these two things that you're
putting together here uh they don't
really they didn't they don't really
connect in my mind um
him hanging up the shirt hanging up the
saul persona for good
i i think that's part of the intention
um but there's like so much there's so
much other stuff going on underneath the
surface you know what i mean like i i
how did he get to that point
how did doing a scam and getting away
with it
give him the you know give him the the
clarity that
hey i can do this once but i can never
do it again you know and like i i'm not
saying that that's not
what's happening i just i'm just saying
that i feel like there's some steps
missing in that in that and getting to
that place
and yeah like we we just talked about
the teaser a few minutes ago
it does seem to to hint that that he's
going somewhere and where else would he
go besides albuquerque i guess maybe to
you know
go seek him otherwise uh
you know
she could be involved in that going back
to albuquerque thing um
but it's a mystery right it doesn't it
there's nothing that that makes it seem
certain
i mean the dialogue from that teaser
sort of seems like a rehashing of mike's
advice that
uh
jimmy said to kim at the beginning of
609 in regards to the one day we can
forget you know so i'm just curious how
that's going to come up
what does it say i can't remember
exactly
i can't remember exactly either but it's
like he's almost trying to beg someone
that they can forget or that eventually
they will be able to forget i don't know
it just had the kind of the same vibe to
me as the uh
as the one day we'll wake up brush our
teeth yada yada yada yeah the very had a
very similar vibe to me again i've only
seen it once right after the episode
airs before i did my gene video last
night but uh
yeah i'm sure we'll both have uh more
elaborate uh perspectives on it when we
do our uh predictions videos for next
week
yeah i'll try to queue it up here and
then um
kind of look at it with the subtitle
i mean the fact that in the trailer he's
uh he's at a crossroad you know that's
you know
a literal and metaphorical moments so
there's a lot that can be said from that
as well maybe that's why he's at a
crossroad or maybe he might be going
back to albuquerque
um i guess yeah people could infer that
the sub say saul chuckles
i get it
you get over it okay
and
that might be the only dialogue there is
huh
unless he says the same thing twice
yeah please believe me he says
um
yeah so yeah i don't know that it's up
to you
i'm not sure if that makes me think that
he's talking to kim necessarily um
oh yeah it says yeah afterwards it says
uh
um
i get it you get over it okay please
believe me before you know it you'll
forget all about it so that that last
line there is what reminds me of uh the
one day we'll wake up and realize we can
forget yeah
yeah i see the parallel there but i
think one of the the recent um comments
said that they thought that it was
hinting that that kim was with him
i'm not sure that
you could say that for sure especially
when you have things like
him saying
after all this a happy ending and
finding out that's about his made-up dog
nippy you know what i mean oh yeah
what a misdirect we were talking about
that so much and theorizing so in depth
just really overthinking and it's just
it just turns out to be a throwaway line
i find i found that really hilarious
honestly i'm like oh of course that's
all that that is
yeah because this teaser it's showing
the it's showing the car pull up to a
stop sign at a crossroads but that
dialogue isn't necessarily coming from
inside that car
based on what we've seen and all the
other ones no yeah no
raja b thank you for the five do you
think there will be any more intense
scenes left in the rest of the season
like like gene avoiding cops evading
cops or something like that
so it will be mellow
[Music]
i'm not really sure i remember whenever
bob talked about the ending when he
first read the ending he said
something to the effect that it's not a
bunch of you know
people shooting guns even though there
was some of that
involved like you know he kind of he
kind of said that then he kind of
tried to be more vague after it right
afterwards it's to me it seems like it's
a you know it's about the character and
it's about his reckoning
and hopefully some sort of redemption
he may have to avoid you know evade cops
he may have to uh you know turn himself
in in a place where
you know there's a lot of hostile people
looking to arrest him
but i i don't know i mean like i said at
the end of my video part of what's
exciting here is that we don't know
what's going to happen next
and uh so i i don't know i think that
it'll be it'll there will be mellow
there there will be some mellow stuff in
there that will be like what we just
watched but
it's you got
walt and jesse returning there could be
some some craziness there some intense
stuff going on there you know there's
it's too hard to tell for me
yeah the the gene evading cops thing
just makes me think el camino when jesse
pulls over and all those cops drive past
him that's that that's the image i got
in my head when you're reading that
yeah robert gay thank you for the 9.99
before season six saw jean and
albuquerque with wanted posters
do we already answer this or is a
different version of the same one
i'm getting some deja vu right now
i don't know if i just saw this in chat
though no we definitely looked at this
before
i mean it's not the same one it's the
same question but he might have asked it
twice because we didn't get to it very
fast
so so robert robert gay uh apologize for
not getting to your question and i
appreciate the 9.99
i think we answered it um
yeah yeah okay yeah we did definitely
talk about this the clothes the clothes
didn't the clothes putting the clothes
back that wasn't the signal it sent to
me that he was ready to turn himself in
um
it's a lot of different ways he could
interpret it though for sure
yeah
really cool thank you for the five
jeffy can't help himself now marion
knows gene is wanted she calls a tip
line
leading to the feds packing up saul's
mansion
um
i think the the feds would would pack up
saul's mansion
once the
once the manhunt starts um
that's what he was running
yeah that's what he was running away
from i don't know if you can connect
those two dots there he he was a public
figure um
everyone knew where he lived he wasn't
in hiding or anything like that for them
to discover that but
she could call tipline i i would like i
would in my in my head i want to see her
do something
more nefarious you know like something
something where she she beats you know
in the way that gene beat jeff in in the
game i'd like to see him i'd like to see
her beat him at his own game you know to
reveal herself as to be
an actual let you know this like a uh
lalo uh gus situation you know they're
they're both
playing at a high level and and coming
after each other but
calling a tip line would set some things
in motion too
i agree
my echo my shadow and me thank you for
4.99 again
lalo shiffrin jim on the run was an
impeccable song choice for the montage
this week thoughts on a montage for the
very last images of the series
um
i agree with what you're saying there
the music was great
they talked about this on the insider
podcast a little bit um
how they how they came up with that it's
funny that it's a gym on the run and and
there's a lot of there's a lot of cool
stuff going on there
uh thoughts on the montage for the last
images of the series uh peter gould said
that this is one of the last montages
they did but he wouldn't say if it was
the very last or if there was still one
to come
oh no you know
but i i just i just i don't bring that
up because like he he literally didn't
say he just said one of the last and and
just hearing that was just like oh damn
you know
like we are getting we are getting close
to the end there's only so many of these
things
these episodes left you know
i will say that i do think how it's
interesting that this this montage is
very jimmy mcgill slip and jimmy-esque
uh and the editing the way it like cuts
between four different screens and three
different screens reminds me a lot of
the uh inflatable montage when saul's
first getting his suits because usually
a jean montage
plays like 40s to 60s music like some
ink spots uh frank sinatra vibes and uh
here it was very much a jimmy mcgill saw
goodman montage so i found that
interesting how they incorporated that
in regards to what he was actually doing
yeah they
i that's one of the things i checked
afterwards because i knew michelle
mclaren did a lot of breaking bad
episodes but only a few of uh better
call saul so whenever i saw that that's
one of the things i did was to look to
see if if she had uh
directed um
you know the uh
the one with the
inflatables and and it was not the case
she was not she did not uh direct that
episode but i like the the way that they
kind of paid homage to it you know
as far as for the end of the series um
i don't know maybe i mean it's such a
big part of this series as montages it
would have to be a pretty good one to
end it on i i kind of like the idea of
jimmy turning himself in and us not
knowing what happens next which doesn't
necessarily
uh you know lend itself to a montage but
i'm i'm open to the idea
andy thank you for the five euro what
are your thoughts on the writers speed
running all remaining loose ends better
call saul never rushed anything like
that before season six
and
i i didn't i don't know
i can't think of a time when they did
that
i don't really [ __ ]
i don't really find season six rushed at
all honestly i mean you want to talk
about speed running a final season let's
uh divert over to game of thrones for a
little bit maybe we can talk about that
sometime but yeah
yeah i know i mean i i don't
i mean it's a perfectly uh you know
it's an opinion you can have it's just
not one i share i guess you know what i
mean like i i think that
um
the time frame and the way that the
those events i mean it did happen one
episode after the other but i mean it
was set up that way so it didn't to me
it didn't feel rushed it felt like
it was like one of those things like if
you told me
lala is gonna or nacho is gonna die in
episode three
howard's gonna die in episode seven and
lala's gonna die in the very next
episode i would have thought that that
sounded ridiculous
but when i watched it play out it all
felt pretty organic to me not not sped
up
yeah i mean this whole time i've been
saying how pleasantly surprised i've
been with uh with how much time they
have left and how quickly they uh they
concluded uh the story arcs it felt like
a subversion of expectation in that
regard and this show has more time to
clean up loose ends than breaking bad
did just with the one granite state
episode so i mean i don't know i think
it's an improvement uh i mean you know
free to have your own opinion but
definitely agree with pete where i
didn't i don't really see it rushed in
my at all
yeah um
hans hans
charler thank you for the two dollars
three episodes kim flash forward call
fish tank
um
fish tank uh is it is
it is maybe one thing that's not really
that they didn't that's unresolved from
the bcs timeline is what happens to the
fish in the fish tank for as much screen
time as that thing has and
the major scenes it's been involved in
yeah i don't think we we we didn't we
definitely didn't see that in um
in the uh the season or the episode one
flash forward to his his uh mansion
so you know
we don't know that it's there
but um
yeah the other things kim i think's
definitely we've
talked about this a couple times already
and that that that call is definitely um
those are definitely things that we can
expect to see in the next two episodes i
think jeffrey townsend thank you for the
15 canadian do you guys think this was
the return of saul goodman or the swan
song of saul goodman
i think it's up for debate i think where
i think it's up for interpretation i
don't think we really know
um in my video i talked about
addiction and and that was sort of kim's
motivation for leaving was that they
can't be together because they can't uh
you know they can't
stop they can't give up the scam
um
that makes it like well what does that
mean about what gene's doing right now
how can you know they say sort of an
addiction
the one you get away with like if you go
back if like if you're sober and you and
you relapse like
if you if you if you get high or you get
drunk or whatever and then you get away
with it that's like the worst thing that
can happen because then
you're it's reinforcing the idea that
you don't need to abstain
and um you know that's the idea is
abstinence is what works
so yeah that's what i think about i
don't know is he relapsing is it
something different
is he in a different place
none of that is absolutely clear to me
just from what we've seen so far
like in that scene it looks like he you
know he said he looks like he says to
himself man i got away with it nothing
bad happened
it feels good it feels good to be able
to plan it out and get it to happen but
you know
under the surface we know that that he
has all of this stuff going on through
his head that that he did throughout the
entire breaking bad timeline
not to to deal with the reality of of
what he you know his feelings were about
what happened before whenever he would
you know
was running scams with the love of his
life and that she she left because she
doesn't want to have anything to do with
that or doesn't think that she can have
anything to do with that and and you
know it
i i don't know i don't have any i don't
have any you know
great answer to this but
i can't wait to find out
i think it's a little bit of column
column a column b he said it is up to
interpretation
uh just to derail for a second i'm
i'm just a bit distracted by chat just
uh chuckling to myself here with all of
the all of the nippy sequel names uh
taking some liberties uh from tom
schnauz's testicle twitter thread except
with nippy we gotta we got the nippy
awakens the last nippy the rise and
nippy the dark nippy rises nippy begins
nippy genesis
i don't know i love all of the uh it's a
nippy nippy too nippy harder
[Laughter]
yeah
you could
it could definitely that's something
that could definitely go on forever as
as the testicles thread has shown us
that's been over like a year's worth of
things by now probably right
oh i don't know i'm enjoying chat right
now just skipping through it you guys
crack me up sometimes
yeah
whisper gaming thank you for the 4.99 i
love this episode to me it was about how
you can't escape who you are
jimmy even seemed to acknowledge some of
his internal pain
yeah i agree that
he may have
agree that he may have and i and i
and i agree that
he he acknowledged that he i don't know
if it's escape who you are as much as
like i can't be this person forever and
i think that that's something we haven't
really talked about too much and you
know that i think is important
i think he he realizes that he that who
he is is it's not compatible necessarily
with uh hiding out his gene for the rest
of his life
um
but where does he go from there does he
create a new persona does he become a
different person
or i mean i don't think he's going to go
back to being saul
and i think you know this shows us
there's a little bit of jimmy inside
there still but um
i don't think it's at all clear where he
goes next
i rocker thanks for the 199
isn't kim from nebraska maybe jean will
see her uh yeah
this is something we talked about and uh
it's definitely a possibility
there's nothing there's no other just
her being there is the only evidence
there is for it though
so we'll just you know we'll have to see
what happens
luke duke thank you for the two dollars
canadian will marion receive saul's
reward money
if she turns them in she will
um
there's definitely motivation there
right now he has some he could he could
say if you do that you're i'm gonna take
your son down with me uh unless she has
a way to neutralize that that we don't
know about
but um
yeah i don't know
that would be that would be part of her
motivation maybe she has a different
motivation that doesn't involve her son
uh also going to prison though or maybe
she doesn't care if her son goes to
prison
i mean uh
kind of an unrelated uh trail rabbit
hole thought process i was thinking of
marion getting reward money elders
getting a lot of money the sandpaper
settlement and then i thought of irene
and i ju
what i'm trying to say is i think it'd
be really cool it's not going to happen
but i i think it'd be really cool to see
irene and
marion in a scene together i think in an
alternate universe they they'd be the
best of friends i don't know if those
actors can get together in a future
project somehow if they can get cast
together but uh yeah i feel i feel like
they'd really get along that'd be a
wholesome moment
it's a random thought
yeah
mike t thank you for the 10. what do you
guys think of this idea that the show
creators are nervous nervous about the
reception of the remaining episodes
peter gould said that half of the
audience will love it and half will hate
it
i i think i read somewhere that he said
it might be divisive
and that he hopes that fans will love it
um i'm not sure if he he's he i don't
think i read anything where he said half
and half something like that but
um i think they what i take away from
that is they're taking some chances and
and i think i like that when tv shows do
that and um they're in a you you're in a
unique position in a way that they can
do that uh some of the shows that that i
know i watch and i care about and i love
they they really they don't really have
that option you know what i mean
seems like they're getting their
episodes cut back all the time and and
they're having to
to pare it down and do it quicker
whereas
we got an extended season here and they
went into it thinking that they had a 13
episode story
and i think that's enough for me to be
excited to see it it doesn't mean that
it'll be good i mean if i don't like it
i'll you know i'll be the first to admit
that but
um
i'm not really uh
because he because they're doing
something different and that gives him
uh
you know that makes him
nervous or anxious or whatever that
doesn't really
i don't i don't worry i'm not worried
about it really not yet not right now
i mean it's always it's always
interesting uh ending a series a lot of
these drama series seem to don't stick
the landing but breaking bad is one that
did
and uh you know there's clearly some
pressure with uh finishing up better
call saul because not only is it better
call saul but the foreseeable future the
breaking bad universe as a whole and in
one of those article interviews uh peter
gould did say something along the lines
of he's never quite seen an ending to
the show like this one and i don't think
those were just uh you know hype words
or whatever i really think that we're
gonna see some sort of original
different ending and uh it was a vince
gilligan said that uh the ending or the
finale isn't just one episode like we're
seeing the finale right now between
episode 9 and 13. it's been across
multiple episodes so i'm really curious
how they're going to finish it and uh
yeah i remember peter gold saying he was
uh
a bit nervous uh i mean i he seems
confident that they stuck the landing
but just a bit nervous about finishing
the series uh when he was in the the
editing room uh finishing up 13 just as
uh the mid-season break was finishing
off so i i have faith in these guys and
i'm really excited to see what they have
in store for us
yeah
tim cappel thank you for the 4.99 you
guys are the best much love to all thank
you for that um
you're the best too
space king two dollars was there
a reward for finding saul there was a
reward poster in a preseason teaser that
said 5 million dollars with saul goodman
aka jimmy mcgill on it
we haven't seen that show up in the
actual
show yet
they've been pretty vague about what
he's running from but
i think there's a i think there's a
really good chance that that is uh
something that's going to happen we're
going to see that teaser and real
in the actual show
josh taylor thank you for the 4.99 i
love this episode and how it was so far
removed from our expectations following
fun and games
the last two episodes felt like finales
what happens next
yeah i agree uh there's something that i
i i'm
ben saying
it's uh it's a great feeling to not know
what's gonna come up next uh not too
many shows can take you there
and they have you know they build up a
lot with these with this world and these
characters so
it's exciting it's an exciting thing um
just uh just just just in denial with uh
with how we're coming to the end of the
show i mean every time a new episode
starts i feel like i'm not ready but
then i just
full send it into the episode and enjoy
the ride you know it's been it's been
quite a ride hahaha but uh yeah i don't
know i don't know it's nice uh nice
being left in the dark and having this
mystery around the final few episodes it
definitely creates a lot of intrigue
around the show as we can see better
coleslaw is like constantly trending on
twitter every week and with good reason
too um
i i think that they're doing a really
solid uh victory lap here with this
final season with bringing back all of
all of the side characters and
concluding every story arc under the sun
in a satisfying way i think i think
they're really sticking the landing so
far and i love the freeze frame that you
have on that mall cop eating that's in a
bun
jim o'hare is a legend
it's actually a sequence it's it's
the cutting
look at the concentration and the
thought that's going into that form
and then and then the ecstasy i mean the
actor does a fantastic job and they can
you imagine how many of those bites he
had to take i mean i'm sure he doesn't
swallow
swallow them all he probably spits them
out in between the takes or something
but
you know that's something that
you don't really think about when you're
watching it live but they shoot that so
many times so for him to
to be eating in every single one of
those scenes and all those different
times whenever he comes to see him like
that's pretty that's pretty uh crazy
yeah
robert gay this is the same question um
this is the third this is the third
version and again i'm sorry if if you
were if you were redoing it because we
didn't get to it but um we i try to hit
everybody's in order and um
this we did
we did talk about this a couple times
already so
sorry this is this is why i usually try
and script my videos because i can go
off the rails pretty easily
well that's why i do streams it's
because i want to have a conversation
instead of just doing this the scripted
thing you know i mean it's a nice change
of that to where i can uh you know have
a conversation and answer questions
but yeah the downside is when you have
so many of them that it takes a long
time to get to the mall
tony corrant thank you for the 499 do
you think that do you think the lalo
nacho line from breaking bad still works
or
not i can buy that he would say that
because i want to make everything fit
but also i don't know
i think that they established the fact
that he'd be afraid of lalo
for the rest of his life
that he might not
be able to
believe the the pretty vague way that
mike explained that he wouldn't be a
problem
so
i think it works i don't think they
really need to do anything else with it
um
[Music]
what do you what do you think chase
well uh
and i mean i i don't know if this is a
weird take or not but i found it a
little bit contrived the way that mike
said
uh what he said to jimmy in uh at the
end of 608 and i went into this in my
review of the episode but just
essentially it's one of those moments
where and usually better call saul
doesn't do this i feel like the walking
dead has a problem with this where
characters say stuff in a way that
actual people don't talk and it's just
kind of like well why can't he just say
lalo's dead why can't he say that i've
seen the body that i'm going to bury him
with howard any one number of these
things to a hundred percent confirmed to
jimmy why
you know you don't have to be worried
about him i know i was wrong before but
this time trust me i see the dead body i
know he's dead right after i leave here
with howard that's what i'm going to go
clean up next
um and he definitely says it in that way
where oh you don't have to worry about
him he's not coming back he's not coming
back just in in sort of a nuanced uh
implication where he's neither
confirming or denying that he's dead
just so that they can make that uh
breaking bad line fit so when you accept
that it's a bit contrived yes it makes
sense it makes complete sense it works
perfectly for the story in regards to
making that breaking line or breaking
bad line makes sense but just taking it
at face value it does seem a little bit
contrived just so that it can make sense
so i do have a little bit of a complaint
there but within universe uh it
definitely makes sense uh
why why he still thinks that he's alive
and they set that up really well but i
do think it's a bit contrived and it's a
little bit frustrating that mike can't
just say he's dead man like i'm gonna go
bury the body he's done don't worry
about it
and and uh yeah and i get what you're
saying and and i and i agree that they
they definitely did that for that reason
you know they wrote it that way for that
reason but i don't think it's really out
of character for mike i mean
mike doesn't really like to give out um
details unless
the person needs to know so i think it
kind of works both ways but you know it
it's not ideal they basically
you know they the the the the good thing
about that throwaway line is they came
up with some great characters and you
know it it brought so much fun
to better call saul but the bad news was
is that
they always had to write sort of back to
it and you know that there's that just
kind of you know
is not not always satisfying you know
i mean i get that mike's like a man a
few words like he's my face he's my
favorite character from breaking bad i
know how the man operates uh that is
very like to uh to act like that and to
uh you know you know kiss and not tell
so to speak so it does make sense that
he would say something like that and and
even even so you know mike was wrong
before so we could tell jimmy that lalo
is dead and jimmy could just not believe
him or just the simple ptsd from
everything that happened and better call
saul could just you know spark when he
sees that grave dug in in front of him
in the desert um so you know all those
things make sense but i don't know it's
just like a small it's like a nitpick
you know it's not a big deal i still
like the episode i still like the scene
just a little little pet peeve i'm not
i'm not like sincerely frustrated by it
it's not an actual complaint it's just
just a little nitpick you know it's just
something worth mentioning
yeah and uh
so you said that you're gonna be
uh checking out yeah
yeah it's about time for me to hit the
old dusty trail um
had a lot of time had a lot of fun here
though was great talking about the
episode
um i will i will just give it give a
disclaimer to the chat feel free to send
me all of your nippy memes on twitter
i'd like to see i'm seeing all of these
alternate alternate uh movie title names
if you want to like take a poster from a
movie and slap the word nippy on it that
would just make my day might call myself
vivid nippy in my review i don't know
i'm just i'm just loving her uh
i'm the one who nips diary of a wimpy
nippy it's it's nip in time i'm i'm
loving it so uh yeah that's always a fun
time thanks for all the questions i
appreciate the support thanks for having
me on pete uh feel free to check out my
channel be covering a lot of gene this
week and uh possibly next week as well
so uh yeah thanks for having me on it's
been a blast
yeah thanks for coming out as always uh
i'm not sure if you're going to come on
on saturday or when we'll see you again
but definitely um we'll be having you on
and uh we'll be talking offline or you
know not on stream like we always do so
thanks thanks and uh we'll i'll talk to
you soon
have a good one
yeah you too
all right so now i will
go straight through and answer all the
questions that are remaining here um
and i'm not going to leave until i'm
caught up so
let's see what happens gold bond 007
thank you for the five dollars do you
think we might see jeff in the breaking
bad timeline since marion said that he
fell in love or he fell in with a bad
crowd in albuquerque uh yeah i think
that's not my initially where my mind
goes to it but i think it's possible um
she she mentioned that
i think it's interesting that he said he
never he's never been there you know
kind of quickly but then
stumbles on the nippy question later so
there's there's a lot of potential in
there for uh that to come back up
it could be you know that she mentioned
that to take his temperature to see what
he thought about it you know that might
have been a very specific uh
thing that she did
we'll see richard seymour thank you for
the five we're in the scouring of the
shire phase of bcs yeah that is
i get the uh i get what you're saying
there i get the comparison that makes
sense
in that epilogue way um jonathan gorder
thank you for the sck-50 hi from sweden
do you think an episode with jesse and
walt will consist of guest star
in the beginning displayed and then the
actor's name
would that be a spoiler
um
i'm not really sure what the deal is
with like the
i mean
part of the credits is that that's part
of what's in their contract so i guess
they could
if they're regular actors or if they get
a guest spot then they you know they're
they're
they would normally get that in the
beginning but maybe whenever they have
something that's a special case like
this uh you know they they
they tell you know they put that in the
contract that it won't be
mentioned i i don't know i mean they've
been
it's funny because i just watched the
brian cranston interview uh maybe a week
ago where he was talking about all the
secrecy that they did to film and then
right before the season came out vince
and peter just announced it you know so
it kind of made all of that seem like it
was
unnecessary um
so yeah i they haven't kept it a secret
at all
um
so i don't know if that would still be a
spoiler to do it uh maybe there'll be a
small amount of people that it would be
that would be surprised but i mean like
the whole you know i've been waiting
every episode this season to see if they
pop up
and uh they haven't yet so it's still
going to be a surprise when it happens
simon mandel thank you for the 4.99
james dell thank you for the ten dollars
fun and games felt like a finale to me
this episode felt like a palette
cleanser i really enjoyed it for what it
was and have no idea where they go from
here and i love that yeah i agree that's
uh that's what i've been saying for the
last two days uh the pallet cleanser
idea is interesting now i think that's a
little bit different than the idea of it
being an epilogue
although those two things you know could
be happening at the same time
it could be the palette cleanser that
exists inside the epilogue uh you know
it's hard to say
and as you
correctly state here
that's something that you can fall in
love with you know that that that not
knowing is a great thing
whisper gaming 4.99 thank you very much
i love this episode to me it was about
how you can't escape who you are yeah
another commenter just said that a
little bit ago
um
you know there's a question
you know of can people change
and
you know they do obviously everybody
changes everybody evolves but
there's certain things that
you can't escape right and that's what
you're kind of saying here
um
i we'll see where the jury goes like i'm
a little bit mixed like i'm a little bit
mixed on on how i fall on some of this
stuff
just because there was such revelations
at the end of episode nine and it really
recontextualized how i think about jimmy
as a person and his transformation as
being saul goodman and gene
and when we went into this i really kind
of had the idea that that his his gene
existence was uh
very difficult it was a very difficult
time
where um
you know
he wasn't he wasn't he wasn't enjoying
himself you know i mean like things were
not
and um
here
we see him
turn is to his old way like you know
that he could
he can make it a little bit better by by
running the scam
but what does it say about who he is you
know that's the question
scrolling scrolling scrolling
all right so that's buenor kemper thank
you for the five uh recognize this from
the last stream
so thanks for coming back beyond being a
great episode this one was a nice
breather
breaking bad was so
unrelentingly dark toward the end that
it almost hard to watch at times yeah
this is um
this is true
um you know there there was
they they did do this to an extent with
um
granite state although it was it was a
lot more brutal like what he was kind of
going through in his exile i guess um
but yeah i i
i agree that it was
it was a nice shift away from all the
heaviness that that each of the last
episodes um
had and like i said i kept expecting
that
it to shift because of that for that
reason i kept expecting
it to turn dark and it just never did um
not yet
dracarus [ __ ] thanks for the 499.
what's your fave scheme jimmy saul gene
i think the howard scheme is the
greatest had the most planning moving
parts and executed perfectly yeah that's
what would come to mind that was the
most impressive one
was the howard scheme
the the outcome of it was was was pretty
uh terrible and
it's hard to say because they're all
they're all so good like even this one
as he's going solo there's so many
moving parts and so many things that he
has to
nail down and get right
that it's always pretty impressive um
i was i don't know i was looking through
some of their old scenes and you know
the stakes kind of get things get a
little more complex as they go as kim
gets more involved
so yeah i think naturally that
that the howard one is the most
impressive and um
i don't know maybe the uh
maybe the um
the heel one is is kind of the most fun
i i i liked i i really liked the way
that that played out and you know jimmy
doing the phone calls and and everything
like that was a whole nother level at
that time you know we hadn't seen them
do something that involved yet i don't
think um
that's what i would say
coming on down maybe we're getting a
little bit closer to no we're still an
hour behind so
nice to see so much activity in the chat
and i hope that the uh
the the mods are
helping out a little bit because it did
get a little bit crazy in the last one
being a bear thank you for the 9.99
great work as always jimmy using elders
to get an upper hand in the earlier
seasons to get used by an elder at the
end yeah that i definitely
we've been talking about that we've been
talking about him underestimating her
and uh that would
maybe that would be feel like a little
bit of justice for irene
or something along those lines
mark barris thank you for the five gene
and saul are so different saul would
have solved the situation with the trip
to belize
um yeah i mean i i underst i get what
you're saying here their attitude is
different
uh gene is gene's situation is
is different more because that he can't
he he's restrained in a way that saul
wasn't i mean that was the whole thing
right
after kim left that left
jimmy to
that left him unrestrained like she was
the last person that believed that that
he was good
you know the the world kept telling him
that he was
terrible
you know that he was you know what what
what he feared because of what you know
he he can never live up or make chuck
accept him right so the world kept
telling him that that was true that that
chuck was right and kim was the only one
who
um
stood up for him so it's pretty sad that
when she's leaving she's leaving for the
fact of like we're doing this because
it's better for both of us but it's also
the thing that lets him just
go and you know
unrestrained into
being the guy who we saw at the end of
that episode
nick lemke thank you for the 9.99 as a
nebraskan this episode is so accurate to
how we speak
if i had a buck for each time i spoke
about nebraska football while eating a
cinnamon roll
i'd have a ca a pile of cast the size of
a volkswagen
i you know i hadn't thought about that
like i said earlier i i never went
through
or spent any time in nebraska
and um you know i never really thought
of that as being a place that had like a
big accent necessarily um
but yeah that's cool it's good to know
that that that catch i mean i i assume
that they shot all this stuff in
albuquerque still
but um
it's cool that that it it works for
someone who's there and um
it'll be interesting i wonder how much
jim o'hare
looked into that you know like how much
he researched that and how much is that
is just him being himself
jeremy harris thank you for the 4.99 you
as both run great channels do you think
there's still untold significance to the
golden toilet
tequila bottle stopper well
the tea the kela bottle stopper
is
i don't know if there's anything more to
it we you know we saw kim le leave and
we know that he kept that and and his
apartment and that whole place is filled
with stuff that he kept
pieces of jimmy in a way you know what i
mean so
i'm not sure if there's more um
it's uh
there's enough and the golden toilet i i
just feel like that kind of
aesthetically
uh you know fits in with everything else
that's going on there
um
i always thought the golden toilet was a
great sign that that kim wasn't there
early on you know that you wouldn't
think that that
you couldn't imagine her living inside
that place and um
even when it you know kind of
made it a little bit more gray of like
maybe she was you know really the one
driving all the stuff that happened with
saul i'm glad but that they resolved it
as they did and i was just talking about
that in the last question so i don't
want to say it again but
um i'm not sure if there's untold
significance there beyond that
my guess would be
no
stephen eurocevic thank you for the five
how do you think
how do you both think francesca reacted
to kim and jimmy's breakup she seemed to
really love kim
what keeps her tied to saul just money
um
yeah i do think so
i do think that that is is is what it is
um
the actress was on
the insider podcast last week and and i
think she said as much mostly you know i
mean
um
she said she did look up to kim she
tried to play her that way and uh
when they said why did she stick around
saul's office
she said money and that was it
scott moranis thank you for the 9.99
katie thank you for the a299
what would be more satisfying jimmy
caught or free
i think him making the decision to turn
himself in would be the most satisfying
seeing him get caught is there's not
really much satisfaction in that other
than
um
i don't know because he's not really
hurting anybody where he's at right now
he's just miserable so him getting
caught it doesn't really
it doesn't really do much
we i think we saw at the end of this
episode what it looks like when he's
free
um
it's okay
but it feels like there's some some
unresolved stuff still hanging out so
some people like the idea of him being
caught and uh you know becoming a
popular you know popular guy in prison i
i don't really
i don't really
i don't know i mean prison is prison
it doesn't matter if you enjoy yourself
in there or not it's awful
it's it's
much worse than um
you know being living in a uh
in a condo
and working as a manager
at cinnabon as bad as that may be so
yeah
i don't like to see i don't like to
think of anyone i like being locked up
that's horrible
my echo my shadow and me thank you for
the 4.99 again could gene letting jimmy
back into his life marco's ring checking
out the goddy clothes ultimately be his
downfall
could he become more complacent yeah i
mean it's possible
that's where it felt like it was going
right up into the point where he picked
up the clothes and put them down
then it made it a little bit more
complicated but uh we'll have to wait
and see because i don't think it really
gave us enough information yet cp show
thank you for the five do you think the
main image on the newspaper jean reed
spells out the final three episodes
do you think the main image on the
uh
i don't know what it is
i don't know how to answer this um i got
a picture in here of him looking at
sports
cheers tears
relief
hmm
it's a good question
the tears is the one that's a little bit
harder to uh to figure out but that
could
that could be
yeah that that's that's a i like it i
like where your mind is going
big mac 076 thank you for the 499. i
couldn't help but notice marion saying
to gene you're lucky when he tells her
he's never been to albuquerque yeah
that's true
it almost makes it seem like
she has more experience with it other
than just
jeffy having a bad time there following
him with wrong people
but she doesn't make it explicit
agent neptune thank you for the five
marion confesses to gene that ed was her
husband
and she already knows about saul
that's a twist on the old uh she's
ed's wife or ed's mother
theory
they could have a connection but i mean
whenever you think about them being
connected to something important
in albuquerque it always
jumps out to me that yeah we have to
remember that these people came together
as a random chance you know what i mean
like these people didn't seek out they
didn't seek him out they didn't um
they didn't know he was there or any of
that stuff you know he he went to the
hospital because he passed out and jeff
was the cab that came
so i don't put a lot of stakes in them
being you know connected to something
important back in albuquerque i could be
wrong but you know
we'll see
constant campbell thank you for the 499
when the high heels were shown clucking
through the clothing store i thought for
a second it was going to be kim
just me and i think no i think everyone
thought the same thing
at least everyone i've talked to so far
and i definitely seen comments about it
on my last video too
i think that was the intention and i
think it worked perfectly i think that
uh
i you know it was just universal
maybe it's kim
joe montoliba
monte montielbo thank you for the 199.
for almost ninety
carol burnett was awesome as macaroon
i agree
um
such a great thing and her and bob
really really played off each other well
um
i'm not sure if they've ever been
anything together before but
you know that was uh they they seemed
like uh you know they they just
played off each other so well
scott morenis thank you for the 1999.
that is a
that's very generous gene had a freudian
slip
where he mentioned being forgotten
what are the odds that gene slips back
into saul and gets himself
and possibly kim caught up
that would be a real gilligan and gold
ending
it's it's kind of hard to see a path to
where he gets kim in any trouble um
everything he's on the run for here
would be related to walter white which
is so far we don't know that she had
anything to do with any of that and it's
it doesn't look likely
um
that is the that's that's that's what i
was talking about you know before when i
was talking about you know that whenever
you if you're in sobriety and you you
you go out and you use your drug of
choice or you know drink your alcohol or
whatever it is getting away with it is
like a bad
thing because
if you get away with it once why
wouldn't you try again
and you know that that
that stood out to me a lot in that last
scene so
i just can't you know i i
like i said i think he i don't think he
can he can continue as
um
i don't think he'd continue as gene as
as it was
but i don't think that it's it's a
hundred percent that that means that
he's going to
do
you know something completely crazy i
think it's i think it's more likely that
he'll be if he's exposed it'll be
because of
an outside force if something on this
one comes back at him somehow or if you
know kim comes back or if marion turns
out to be some kind of
criminal mastermind that we just don't
know about yet
raul dillon thank you for the 199 what
you what do you think this series legacy
is um
i mean that's a complicated question
because this series as itself
you know there's always the questions of
like what which which is better one of
the other and i feel like at this point
they're they're all just the
two parts of a bigger thing
when i think about it you know what i
mean like
a lot of what this show
does so well they never would have been
able to do if if breaking bad hadn't
been such a hit
i think for me you know just if
really simply what this show did was it
from its legacy for me was to show that
they could really do some great
character work
in a prequel
where things are
inevitably going to happen and you know
that
i mean
i think that they did that in a way that
um
no show had done before and that's what
i would say you know that they
they showed that
a uh you know a prequel series can be
completely thrilling and uh worthwhile
victor figueretto thank you for the are
ten dollars do you think
do you guys think the mall con is over
i think it is
but i'm not sure that there will be that
that that that it's consequence-free
you know
i think there's potential that some of
that might come back um
but as far as like
robbing the store
and going to eat you know going to
deliver cinnabon i think he's done with
that for now i think i don't think that
there's like another phase to it that we
haven't seen yet
tommy gavin thank you for five dollars i
don't know if anyone mentioned this but
the rhyming memorization for jeff was a
copy of dirty dozen
when they are planning their raid ah i i
didn't catch that reference um so good
catch if that's the case i believe you i
hope i'm
i hope i'm not being taken for a ride
felipe troncoso thank you for the 1999.
that is very generous i thought gene's
plan was for jeff to fail
and get him behind bars to fix that
situation so when he slipped i was
expecting him to be excited and tell the
guard to turn around
i wasn't 100
sure but
i i assumed
he wouldn't want that to happen
because you know he could be implicated
and and he doesn't want anyone to find
out who he really is
as far as like what he was trying to do
i mean it made it made perfect sense in
retrospect and you know i kind of
figured that's what it was he was trying
to
dirty him up so that he he couldn't you
know he so he could change the power
dynamic around a little bit because you
know
jeff was holding all the cards uh
he could you know he was holding that
idea that i can just call
and take your freedom away
but i wasn't 100 sure that he was uh
you know that that's how it was going to
play out until it did
and uh
he did such a great bob owen kirk did
such a great job of of
making me
you know making me feel uh gene's terror
in that as he's as he's looking over his
shoulder
espejo thank you for the 4.99 i'm trying
to i'm trying to give kim and mrs
kettleman that peanut butter crunch
but punch my guy trying to make some
coffee
okay
thanks for the super chat
kww wild or kw wild child one thank you
for the ten dollars kim being pregnant
is an interesting twist to me maybe the
call is from the child kim has been
raising
and saul is aware he is a dad but is
unable to see his child
because of the life he chose
um
where
well i mean there would have to be a
twist in the breaking bad timeline then
uh it's not we we discussed this earlier
it's not impossible
i don't know
i don't know that we would say
i mean it's so complicated like
are you saying that you the life he
chose in that she broke up
and then he decided to do what he did
and then
and then she came back and said hey you
can have this kid in your life if you if
you if you aren't saul goodman because
you think he would walk away from it at
that point
if given the choice so
that seems a little bit
difficult
you know if she was taking the child
away to
if she was taking the child away
to protect it
then
it doesn't really matter what kind of
life he chose
um
we'll see we'll see
brian hubbell thank you for the five
will jimmy return to albuquerque to turn
himself in at kim's behest
the dillinger of the area echoing the
advice he gave walt
i'm not sure why she would
suggest that
i guess that's the question i would have
him turning himself in has to solve a
problem and right now the the
we he doesn't have the problem we're
waiting for that to develop i guess in
the next episode because
as far as we can tell he's doing just
fine at the end of of 610 so yeah that's
what i would you know i would say it's
going to be marrying it's going to be
coming from kim or it's going to be some
of this stuff that he's doing now coming
back on him
i don't really know what it is yet
yo ernesto had the most
bunchable face i hated him
that's the feeling you can have those
are those are valid feelings there
moises
8 hn ic8 199. scott newhouse is demand
highly recommend his bits yes scott is
the guy who is helping out down there
and uh i just saw his his
channel
link posted and you guys should check
that out it was very
very nice of him to volunteer to help
out
modding this stream
dead beef thank you for the five dollars
the bad crowd that jeffy was involved
with was in this
the notorious coke addict howard hamlin
he was a paralegal at hhm just be just
kidding that be crazy yeah that made me
laugh so thank you for that
what is this when do we get to see how
saul gets the bets black book like i
also wish they showed some corrupt abq
cops in the breaking bad bcs universe am
i right g
uh yeah i could see that
i could see that coming back up or or
not i mean
it's clear that he gets the book
um
it's clear that after
uh kim leaves that he might think it's a
good idea to get the book because
he's going to double down on his
criminal lawyer
thing but
i mean the main reason i don't think
they're going to show it is because i
don't know that they're going to go back
in time that far
but
yeah they don't they don't show a lot of
cops either way in the uh breaking bad
universe you know we don't they don't
get that perspective they're usually
just sort of side characters
other than you know hank and the dea and
his people around him so
yeah i mean there's a lot of corruption
in in
in police uh that they did kind of touch
on it with mike's backstory in 5-0
one of our favorite characters was a
crooked cop but um
i'm okay with them not doing too much
police stuff and
better call saul in general because
hank's storyline it would kind of feel
like it was the same thing
nick ball thank you for the ten dollars
marion is kim's mother
jeff's
kim's half-brother
and how earth
father george may be kim's father making
howard and kim brother and sister
well you got them all in there
that would be
absolutely
insane but
you never know
i thought that
when i was listening to the insider
podcast
i thought that they they slipped up with
something because
pat healy who plays jeff said that he um
he read for for howard's father but then
he said it was a long time ago earlier
so it must have been something that they
cut because i thought at first i was
like wow they're bringing howard's
father
back
or into the story but it was a false
alarm melissa s thank you for the five
dollars still hoping that marion is
kim's mom and jeff's sister it works if
you think about it
i think she may still pull a scam on
gene regardless
yeah like i said i i don't you know it's
not impossible but i i just don't know
how you get around the fact that he just
ended up
um
picking
her ex-husband up from from
the hospital
randomly
and that's how they all came together
alan chow thank you for the 9.99 they
explored the theme of actions having
consequences not only with bad choices
but even good ones
kim did a good thing leaving jimmy but
even then that still indirectly led to
chaos of breaking bad
yeah i just mentioned this a minute ago
and i and i agree that you know
she
she she did it for the right reasons
and it makes it even a little bit more
tragic that
it went bad
you know that
that hurt cutting that tie
was the thing that was keeping him
somewhat
uh you know somewhat respectable and it
was all gone after that
moises espejo thank you for the 9.99 you
yo don't you guys think that maybe
seeing some crops crep cops in the
albuquerque region would have been a
cool element of the show
also when do you think or how do you
think saul got
the black book mystery um
this is sort of a repeat of your last
question so
i don't really have anything new to add
but
thanks for for asking again thank you
uh melting crayons thank you for the
five kim convinces jimmy to turn himself
in to help skyler avoid legal trouble
chance to see her marie and walt jr
[Music]
so like what the kim sees it on tv and
then she feels bad so she says jimmy
should turn himself in
i'm not sure i mean i think you know
kim's
kim's feelings would be maybe a remorse
would be tied to howard i think more
than anything
and he's kind of luck he's kind of been
dealt with
so i it's hard to say how she's going to
end up
back in his life if she does end up back
in his life
bobby burke thank you for the three
could this be the last we see jean
happy ending
i thought that briefly during that
episode but i i don't think so anymore
the more i think about it there's just
not too much other
questions to answer so
i don't know where else you know i don't
know where they go instead
and you know like i said uh several
times that i i do think that
his story there's more to it than him
just uh you know getting away with a um
getting away with the scam
i mean it's fun to watch it i'm glad he
did it
it's always impressive
but i don't think that his story ends
there even though it did feel like a
finale in a lot of ways cody and palmer
thank you for the 4.99 what theory did
you guys guess correctly that you're
most proud of
p.s you guys are awesome thank you
um
man i have to think i don't know um
i i don't necessarily get proud
either way i mean
so much stuff is is is like hive mind
now you know what i mean like it's hard
to even to know which ideas were your
own and which ones you just adopted
um
i'm trying to think
in this season
i mean i instantly liked the idea of
of uh
of
i mean recently of marion being jeff's
mom but i you know i didn't come up with
that myself i heard somebody else say it
if i think of another one i'll tell you
thanks for the question and thanks for
uh you know coming to the stream
jared markowitz thank you for for the
499 jeff's car jeff carr's air freshener
dental the one that kim had in court any
idea why also by the way you can
actually call the number to report nippy
interesting i know that they you can
call a lot of the numbers and they
they're real
and i hadn't thought about calling that
one so that's that's cool um
i don't i don't think there's a
satisfying answer to why she had the
same one
it's funny because there was so much uh
talk about that and that was and that
made a lot of people try to you know i
myself included try to figure out how
those two things could be connected
together
i never liked the idea that she might be
have hired gene just for that same
reason that i just said that i don't
like a lot of those other ones because
he randomly showed up at the at the
hospital to pick up uh gene he wasn't
looking for him
but
what's really funny is that that that
vanity fair video where they read fan
theories
ray seahorn admitted that whenever she
shot that scene that she had no idea
that that was the same uh air freshener
she didn't know what the person was
talking about whenever she read the
question so that that kind of even made
that seem a little bit colder it's just
sort of a nod
kind of like showing the um
the disappears card you know they kind
of put it in there to think make you
think it's possible
that she's not just gonna leave jimmy
that she's going to
need to go because the the we know that
the uh
the disappearer exists but she didn't go
that route you know so sometimes
they do they did they have a history of
throwing some red herrings in there in
this season
blue chicken man thank you for the five
do you think we will see mike at all
during the breaking bad timeline mike
has made men a major part of bcs from
the start
and we and we know so much more about
him now yeah and i think that's the
thing you know like i don't
i like mike he's a great character
i don't know what else
i don't there's not there's not burning
questions that i need to have answered
about him
um
mostly everything about how he is makes
sense i mean there's a little bit he's a
little bit closer to
uh
you know he's a little bit more
personable with jimmy at this point in
the story
but he also seemed pretty
disgusted about what they did to howard
so you know i could say well that's
that's why because he he sees just how
petty and ridiculous they are and that
you know
normal people get hurt as a result
right so
i would like to see him
if it makes sense
for
what's going on with saul at that time
and uh you know it's had to go from
there
because i can't think of any big
question that i need to have answered
about him in the series i really liked
the ending that they gave him um
in episode nine i thought it was was was
was really kind of perfect um
and so i hope whatever they do with him
after that
doesn't take anything away from that if
they do bring him back you know
scrolling here
seeing a lot of familiar names that's
always nice thanks for everybody thanks
everyone for coming out
um
tin omen thank you for the five dollars
is it just me
or season one to three the best thoughts
uh i've heard other people say that
and i guess if that's your your thought
then you then you really enjoyed this
episode um
i really liked i really liked chuck i
really liked the um
just the brutal conflict between those
two brothers and the way that you know
they know so much about each other and
they and they you know they use it
against each other in the worst ways
that was really compelling tv but i
thought that season four was excellent i
thought season five was possibly
one of the best you know i mean i i
can't say that i liked the i can't say
that i like the first three seasons
better than what's come after them you
know
i like it all
llamas youssef thank you for the 279
canadian could marion be malt walt's mom
is he one of her boys
i don't think so i mean is it possible
of course
but i i don't i don't
i don't see how they i mean how how do
you explain that how do you explain gene
ending up in
walter white's
mother's house drinking schnapps
because it wasn't manufactured it's
something that happened organically so
how do you like do you want your show to
do that kind of thing
because it feels to me like it would be
a cheap uh gotcha surprise that that
doesn't really make a lot of sense
on insider they said all directors for
last episodes came in for a crash course
on black and white well the only color
the rest of the way be the breaking bad
flashback
it could be um
i yeah i mentioned this earlier and they
don't say that they that they were only
going to be using black and white but it
did seem
very possible
that
um tom snozz who is you know doing the
next one vince gilligan who's doing the
one after that that those guys will be
including black and white scenes in
their episodes
tony
b24247 thank you for the 199. possible
saul repped jeff in albuquerque and
doesn't remember
that does seem possible
uh
not sure to what end though you know
what i mean
and again
it would be a a pretty big well i guess
it wouldn't be
that big of a
surprise um
he he defended a lot of people that's a
lot better than
than
marion being uh you know somebody's
mother or something like that but
i don't know what to end that would be
like the the you know he
they screw him over it doesn't really
matter he was using his his
status against him anyways
water and fire tarot thank you for the
499. the front of that newspaper
validates it's october 2010 because the
pain the rangers played the raise in the
alds
in october 2010. that's another um
that's another piece of evidence that i
didn't recognize and uh just furthers my
belief that it's october 2010 so thanks
for pointing that out
johann
gamble putty thank you for the 4.99 when
walt and jesse returned do you think
they will see why saul had body armor
and a makeshift potty in the golden
palace
thank you for your analysis
um yeah well he had a
a safe room in there
giving his fear of the cartel i thought
that made perfect sense um
so i don't know if you're
you're
thinking that there would be another
reason that he did that or how he he
specifically decided to put that in
there
um i mean he worry you know whenever
things were getting towards the end of
breaking bad he you could see that he
was wearing a
bulletproof vest under his suit you know
saul goodman was
so they kind of set up the idea that you
know he wore uh he wore those
and
i i thought that the um
you know that was just a natural
extension of his paranoia about
his time with lalo salamanca m thank you
for the ten dollars kim might not be
able to change she had a more she had a
more ruthless side than jimmy ever did
he didn't want to take down howard but
it did it mostly to please kim and he
wouldn't have been so cruel to cheryl
i wouldn't agree with that necessarily
um that's not my take on the two
characters
he didn't want to take down howard uh
she
she pushed for it because she was trying
to bring jimmy out of his funk that he
was in after being in the desert
i mean she wanted revenge against howard
but that wasn't that wasn't the pure
reason it's not that simple i guess what
i would say and um
he wouldn't have been so cruel to cheryl
i mean
he wasn't at that point because she
stepped in and did what had to be done
but i don't know that you would say that
he he wouldn't i mean
he did some pretty bad things in the
series you know
um
you know just i always think about irene
whenever if you're ever
you know if you're ever confused i mean
i i like jimmy i i think he's he's he's
mostly good inside somewhere you know
what i mean
i don't think i think some of the things
he does some of what he's good at leads
to um
bad consequences you know but
um
i don't know that i would say that he
couldn't be as cruel as she was there if
the shoe was on the other foot if she
was trying to convince her and it wasn't
working i think he absolutely was
stepped up to protect his to protect his
partner and uh
the lie they had going there
karaoke buzz thank you for for the five
uh do you think gene will end up dying
anything is possible i already miss
cliff's facial expressions
i don't think he would die
um
but like you said anything's possible i
mean i can't i don't really have much to
add there
um
because it kind of depends on the next
two episodes doesn't it
where he's left now you know i i i just
can't say i can't really
say for sure
if i think he would die
felix thanks for the one dollar i
appreciate it i think i have now
gotten to the end i think we're caught
up here
and uh we've hit the
three hour mark
so
uh
and the
numbers are going down a little bit
there if you have any final questions
now is the time to ask them because i am
going to
roll on out of here i want to thank
everybody for showing up i want to thank
the mods uh
you guys seem to have done a great job
as far as i can tell
we'll talk afterwards see if there was
any issues
uh saw a lot of requests for
courtney she will be here on saturday as
far as i know that was the plan um we'll
do a preview
like we did last week so you guys should
come back for that
um
i've been working on two different
videos i've been sort of bouncing around
and um
and therefore not getting either one of
them done with everything else i got
going on so i i am going to try to get
some other videos out this week uh
stay tuned for that
felix you're getting in there at the at
the wire um
thoughts on the diamonds november 12th
lalo
thank you for the two
thoughts on the diamonds is we may see
an origin story for those i'm not sure
how they come into play
going forward but
they conspicuously can you know they
showed them pretty conspicuously and you
know i imagine that though that won't be
the last time we see them
november 12th we talked about this
several times in this very stream
that call is coming
uh you know i hadn't caught that when i
made my recap so i didn't bring it up
but
that call is coming up
and lalo uh
lalo is dead
he's buried under the super lab
i don't know what else to say about that
jimmy's still scared of him he's like a
specter he'll always be scared of him
petco
pavlov
thank you for the bgn 1099. keep up the
good work
yeah i appreciate it and i'll try thanks
for the the uh
the motivation
it means a lot
emma razz thank you for the one dollar
canadian
connor greenwood thank you for the two
dollars canadian after 72 hours moved
merch
now jeff can rat
well the whole problem with him writing
is that
jimmy would be able to
uh
you know he'd be able
to testify against him if he was getting
in trouble then you know
what does he have to lose he can just
turn it turn it back to him and bring
him down together
e minor
two dollars thank you kansas city royals
bag is definitely teasing kim yeah he's
always had that bag from the beginning
and it and it definitely makes you think
about that shirt that she wears later
to sleep in later in the in the series
um
i didn't really think of it as as
teasing canvas because i think it's
inevitable that kim has to come back but
i see what you're saying it does keep
her in our minds in an episode that she
doesn't appear in lemus youssef thank
you for the 279 canadian walt herdsol
going to nebraska could it have told mom
eeee
yeah
but
what
to what end
um
are you saying mom as in that
it's uh
marion if if that's the case like i said
i don't know how she orchestrates
jeff uh
being there to be the taxi that shows up
after he falls down i mean they could
go back and make that make sense like
retcon the whole thing like they were
watching him he paid off a different
cabbie to be the one that pulls up or
something like that but
i'm not sure that's direct the direction
they're going
yeah but what evidence thanks again
conor greenwood would he have against
jimmy
against jimmy he has the
the fact that he's living under assumed
identity
um
jimmy would have
you're
i don't know if you're if you're asking
this backwards or what i mean
jimmy would
would know that he did the scam because
he planned it and he could definitely
you know have some uh
evidence
to it but i mean as far as
jimmy he just has the identification all
they have to do is take his fingerprints
and they would know that that he's he's
actually jimmy mcgill aka saul goodman
not gene takovic
rolo the mexican rallo the mexican thank
you for the 999. you think the ending
will end like the sopranos black screen
i'm not sure but i think that that would
be kind of fitting if he turns himself
in that we don't see anything that
happens afterwards because
i i feel like it's just it's just better
if you if you can
you know
make it up yourself there's we know this
guy so well we watched so much that he
did um
it's just fun to think about what might
happen
i'm not sure it'd be fun to watch all
those things play out in the same way
you know i think that would be a
a pretty good way to wrap it up
oh lunar orbit you just got in there
right as i was
as i was getting ready to shut it down i
mean no problem i'm just saying that
that was good timing on your part lunar
orbit thank you for the five dollars
canadian i'm sure there's no connection
but i like the idea that jeff got the
car freshener from walter white's car
wash yeah i've seen a lot of people say
that and um
could be a fun tidbit but i don't think
we'll ever
get any confirmation of that
ah yeah that's what i thought you were
saying i messed up what was jen connor
um
i mean he planned it so he could have he
could have some kind of evidence he
could have
you know i i we we know he's smart
enough that i i don't think it it
requires too much of a suspension of
disbelief to think that
he might have saved something
that he didn't mention in that
conversation but he would have it if he
needed it
he's a lawyer too you know what i mean
he he understands how the process works
trekkers [ __ ] says that
as all those cut tags have jeff's
fingerprints on them
um you know i was thinking about that i
wanted to go back and look it
that seemed like a weird thing how they
he was cutting those
but i didn't get a chance to go back and
re-watch about like was he leaving them
behind and when they find those before
they do um i mean couldn't that be
evidence like that they found before
they did uh
inventory i wasn't sure but
thank you for the 199
and guys i am
busted so i'm gonna get out of here
thanks for coming if you can't get
enough come back on saturday and we'll
do it again
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon